Eh,
we're going live folks.
Dana White's not even here yet.
We're going live anyway.
We don't give a fuck.
We're crazy work.
Gangs
stir.
We're going live.
I'm to tweet it even
though we're already live.
That's how crazy.
I am damned going live.
I'm writing it,
but I'm actually doing
it at the same time.
Boom.
Sock upon it.
The Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com if you
go to o n n I t and use
the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10% off any and
all supplements including Alpha brain,
my favorite shit on the planet.
And to take it every
morning with my Kale shake.
Now I have like a whole
system that I set up.
Brian,
you've got a lot of things that I take
with my Kale shake and one of them is a
spirulina and Chlorella,
chlorella,
chlorella.
It's a new um,
cloak.
Cholera,
cholera,
Green Shit,
son.
Supergreens okay,
let's cut to the fucking
nonsense scientific words.
Um,
it's um,
there,
there are these um,
uh,
it's a super green supplement
that you can add to your,
uh,
your diet.
And just automatically get a lot more
phytonutrients and a lot more vegetable
matter and all the good shit that comes
from alkaline forming vitamins and
minerals.
Could have just had a VA.
I have that too.
Well I have a massive a
Kale shake in the morning,
but I also take it with that just to
give it an extra kick in the Dick.
And then I throw some Alpha Brandon there.
I also throw some,
um,
uh,
I tweeted it today.
I instagrammed it.
I throw some fish oil in there as well.
And a,
a multipack a pack of,
um,
I take,
I think it's called the things
they called true athletes,
Super Pac or something like that.
But it's a really good common atory,
a little package of essential nutrients.
All this stuff that I talk about
except for the vitamin pack.
We're going to have
vitamin packs eventually.
We don't have it yet.
We're working on that shit.
We just trying to get put together the
best formulation possible when it comes
to a vitamin packs and we don't want
to fuck it up the first time out of the
gate.
So we're,
we're doing our diligence just like we
are with this a testosterone supplement
that we just released.
T plus we talked about
doing this for a long time,
but we wanted to make sure that,
first of all,
is there anything out there
that actually does help?
And it turns out yes,
there is.
There's some stuff called magnesium
aspartic acid that has been shown in at
least one test to increase
free testosterone by 42%.
That's fascinating stuff.
Um,
it also has this stuff called Long Jack.
uh,
and a couple of the different
ingredients that are,
that help elevate natural
dopamine levels and uh,
allow your body to produce
its own testosterone at a
slightly elevated levels,
slightly being as high as 42%
of this study is different.
Between that and taking
syn synthetic testosterone,
like people that are
taking testosterone shots,
you're probably taking
100% of what your body,
maybe 200% of what your body is a is
experiencing if you have low test levels.
So this is not,
it's not that strong,
but it is natural.
And the difference being,
it's not going to shut
down your endocrine system.
It's not going to shut down your own
body's ability to produce hormones.
And um,
you know,
that's a,
that's what you want.
Until we can figure out how to turn
people into robots and that's coming.
Okay,
so just no,
no,
that's on the way.
There's a lot of other
cool supplements there.
If you go to o,
n n I t use a code name,
Rogan,
he will save yourself 10%
off any and all seven events.
That does not include all
the fitness equipment,
which we just got a new supplier of
kettle bells in their fucking Badass.
Jamie had to wrestle him out of the box.
Yeah.
Are we ever going to have the secret ones?
Yes.
They're working on it,
son.
Shit takes time.
You gotta go to China.
You want to go to China?
It's a long way.
Go to China.
I will be,
if you want me to go there,
I would tell him Brian,
I would love to get a lot of work.
Yeah.
O n n I t end socket.
All right.
Had the music.
Can I ask you to say
that the American comedy,
Oh yeah.
March 14th,
or we're having a death squad show there.
It's going to be me.
Hinchcliffe a Teebo and some big
surprises to be announced soon.
Well,
just so you guys is a very tiny kitchen,
was very funny.
Son
Calming Comedian,
uh,
as,
as tea tea's a hilarious guy.
Always been hilarious.
He's,
uh,
he's,
of of a true veteran of the
store comic store veteran.
Yeah.
Um,
so that sounds like a great show.
It's a great fucking club that American
comedy company has just set up.
Perfect.
Beautiful downtown.
Well,
that area,
what does that,
how did,
was it a slight at gaslight?
Gosh,
it's so crazy dope area.
So it's such a cool little spot number
to see if I can get a video DJ to open it
up,
uh,
with,
which is the guy that cuts
videos live instead of deejaying.
Whoa.
Okay.
I've never even heard of that before.
Yeah,
it's David.
Uh,
David did remember we interviewed David,
uh,
the artist David or David Cho.
Yeah,
she does that too.
Yeah.
Oh,
no,
he doesn't do that.
No,
I'm like,
God,
I'm making shit up man.
This motherfucker,
he making shit up again.
Can you believe what I have to,
Oh my God,
I'm sorry.
No,
we had this guy on this
desk squad podcast.
Oh,
okay.
Was it a Kevin Pereira
and podcast Kevin prayer,
the gentleman's name.
Do you remember?
I can't remember right now.
Mike relm.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're fine.
Friday night the freak party pulls
into Anaheim the grove in Anaheim,
Joey Diaz and Wa.
And uh,
so that's tomorrow night.
We were fucking fired up.
It's,
it's going to be great.
I'm fired up.
I love working with Joey in Anaheim.
Anaheim is where the UFC is at.
So,
uh,
I'm doing the weigh ins and then right
after the winds were going out and doing
the show.
So that's,
um,
Friday night Anaheim the grove.
Dana White's on the way,
but fuck it.
We're starting.
Anyway.
Role is Brian
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan by night all day.
Well,
we're waiting right now
for Dana white to show up.
He,
uh,
took,
a car from Anaheim.
And if you know anything about
California Southern California,
Los Angeles in particular,
it's a fucking mess.
The highway is the most ridiculous
shit you've ever seen in your life.
It's been ridiculous
ever since I moved here.
I moved here in 94,
but it's gotten steadily and steadily
more ridiculous to the point where it's,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's like,
you can't fix this.
This is just Ooh,
way too many people for that amount of
road and Anaheim's like on one side of
La,
then we're on and it's rush hour.
I don't even know what he's,
he's not gonna be here for hours.
He's been in the car ready for an hour
and 40 minutes to call me at five.
Oh eight.
It's six 40 now.
So he's almost an hour and 40 minutes.
Yeah,
he's,
um,
you're fucked when you
try to get anywhere,
especially down to Orange County.
Jesus Christ,
that drive is insane.
Those poor people that live in Orange
County and then work in La and do that
every day.
I know somebody who does
San Diego every day.
No,
you don't say who the fuck is
that and what's wrong with you?
Go now.
Okay,
what's wrong with him?
Why doesn't he get a place here or there?
I think somewhere does.
I think he works down in San Diego.
Well,
I guess you've got to
do what you gotta do it,
but that's two and a half hours each way.
Right?
That's five hours of driving a day.
How's your car not gonna explode
or your anger?
You could go crazy.
I do Kevin
being once every four months.
Right?
And every time I do it,
I just,
I'm amazed.
I left my house at 6:00 AM and I was
in bumper to bumper traffic at 6:00 AM.
I was like,
you've gotta be fucking shitting me.
The you are just asking
for people to go crazy.
You know,
and people who don't see that,
like fellow Comedians who don't get
up in the morning like you could,
you could be unaware of the
dangers of your environment.
Whereas if you were in that
pressure cooker every day,
driving around every day in
that insane stressful situation,
just insane levels of stress,
day in day out,
Chinese water torture,
monotonous fucking break lights and
gas fumes until you're ready to just go
fucking crazy and just drive your car
off the side of the four oh five fuck
that.
How many people out there are
like that dude from falling?
Oh,
Michael Douglas.
Yeah,
I remember that Shit.
I Dunno.
People they really
identified with that movie.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot of people
with huge anger problems.
I want to say the person's name,
but this guy last night it was,
I was talking to,
I mean the rage in him.
I was just like,
Holy Hell,
you have a built up anger.
Like I don't,
I've built up anger,
but my anger is always just like that guy.
I fucking hate him,
but not to the point where I'm like,
I won't kill him.
He is my last,
well usually when you
find the misplaced anger,
you also fly.
Find a life that's a wreck.
Yeah.
Like almost
always I give the anger doesn't match the,
the actual situation.
It's like they're using that situation
as a focus because focusing on their own
life is just too fucked up.
It's too confusing.
It's too much failure
and bullshit in there.
I was like,
why do that?
Let's get mad at him and then all of
a sudden that person becomes the issue
instead of their own fucked
up psychological disorder.
Slash.
Personality.
You know that's usually whenever,
whenever is imbalanced,
imbalanced amount of hate that
someone will show towards you.
That's a,
that's because they're
not looking at that.
I won't south.
So take a look at your own self son.
Don't be getting mad at external sources.
You've got some bitch ass genetics.
You got something fucking with you.
I need to get that mirror and
have a sit down in front of it.
This Alyssa lamb thing is,
that's her name.
The woman that would
come in in the elevator.
Don't show that video man,
cause it bums me out.
It's scary,
right?
It's not scary.
It's creepy.
You want to know what it is,
folks?
The video is that girl,
if you haven't heard of her,
she was from,
where was she from?
Canada over Vancouver.
I think she was from Canada and she was,
uh,
in Los Angeles,
apparently by herself and someone killed.
Did,
did they ever say what she was here for?
Like what she's just visiting
or was she just like,
no.
Well,
you know what,
they didn't even say someone killed her.
They said they found her
body in a water cistern.
But I mean,
who knows,
maybe she fucking climbed inside of it.
Maybe we're jumping to conclusions
and maybe she was crazy.
I don't know.
You know,
we don't really know.
Um,
but it's a,
it's a very sad,
it's very unfortunate.
And the elevator videos weird because
not only is like the elevator not working
and she's looks like she's
hiding from somebody,
but then she starts doing like this
weird trippy arm thing that it looks like
she's either on drugs or if she's
possessed by the devil or something.
Yeah.
That's what's fucked up about it.
It's like a Guillermo del Toro movie.
Like,
you know,
it's like you're watching
paranormal activities.
Not that that's a
Guillermo del Toro movie,
but I just saw that mama movie.
So it's,
that shits on my head.
The Mama Mama,
the De Toro horror movie.
Yeah.
It's fucking scary.
It's legit.
Scary.
Glom on to del Toro is a bad motherfucker.
You ever see Pan's labyrinth?
Yes.
That's a great,
yeah,
it's wicked.
He's a very original,
very original and very interesting.
But um,
that uh,
that movie,
if you,
if you look at this
elevator video footage,
you easily could be
something from a movie.
Did you imagine if someone
fake to fucking murder?
Yes.
Yeah.
A advertisement for the
next pair of normal,
like CNN was in bed with
paranormal activities and they,
they,
it's coming to that already,
that mermaid thing that they did on TV
where they pretended they actually had
fucking real married.
They made a documentary
that was a fake documentary.
They made it with actors playing apart
and at the end they had this like special
mermaid thing and you're like,
wait a minute,
what it is?
So obviously fake that like
apparently you watch though.
I didn't even watch it.
You Watch the whole thing thinking like
a lot of people thought it was like
people were saying they
were really mermaids.
Like if somebody was actually believing
they were really mermaids and so people
were tuning into it going,
what the fuck?
There's mermaids and this is like,
I think it was on the history channel.
What?
Yeah.
Let me find out what mermaid special.
Hold on.
We'll net we're going to,
hold on a second.
I need to find out what would it,
cause I'm talking a lot of shit.
I might defame the history channel,
but uh,
it was on one of those things,
man.
Mermaids,
video,
animal planet.
It was on animal planet.
That's even crazier.
Okay.
It's a fucking,
it's the most ridiculous shit of all time.
Like they pretend that there
was a body found it a bit,
a mermaid's had been
attacked by a giant shark.
You know,
like they literally,
the Animal Planet made like a fake movie.
They made him,
they blurred the lines.
They went Gonzo on us.
You know,
they blurred the lines between journalism,
between documentaries and total fiction.
Like they created a,
like you special effects and shit.
So like anybody watching animal planet,
you're assuming you're getting reality.
The worst case scenario is Cesar Milan
is going to pretend a dog's more fucked
up than he really is.
You know,
you're not going to get a guy who's
showing you fucking fake mermaid footage.
Is he still doing the dog whisperer?
I don't know because I
can't talk about that.
But I know something crazy
about that guy that I don't,
it's not really public knowledge
but about one of his dogs.
And what about when was dogs?
I don't know.
I heard from somebody that okay that
he has a pimple that's on his show.
That's all the time.
You know,
like it's like his number
one dog and his pimp,
Yo,
he always is trying to type
to help you but like you know,
pimples and I rescued this pitbull,
this pit bull is now,
look I,
it's great around children
and stuff like that.
And I heard that that
Pippo ended up eating his,
one of his smaller dogs sometime ago.
Very common.
Yeah,
very common pool.
Pull up this mermaids,
the body found video and
prepare to shit your pants.
Okay.
Because this is some crazy avatar stuff.
I'm watching this now.
It is so ridiculous that this
was actually on animal planet
and it's a,
a whale attacks or a shark attacks
a whale and front of this mermaid.
I mean,
this is the nuttiest fucking
thing you've ever seen.
It looks so unbelievably fake.
Oh,
that's super fake.
It looks so unbelievably fake.
This.
Yes,
yes,
dude.
Of course it's not real.
Look up.
Go to the animal planet.
Web website,
animal.discovery.com look up mermaids.
The body found it's a video
on the animal planet there.
That's it.
Look at this ridiculous shit they
were showing an animal planet.
How many hillbillies or sitting
at home watching is going.
I'm telling you it is animal planet.
We are watching animal planet.
We're,
we are watching a fucking mermaid.
It's a real fucking mermaid.
Where's the video?
Play the video.
It's your Internet.
It's,
I've got it right here.
I'm running it.
I,
that's probably why it's so dumb.
It's so dumb.
It hurts my brain.
It looks so fake here.
I'll,
I'll stop it.
So maybe you'd be able to
get it right Internet here.
So wack.
But only for a few more days.
It's going to be fixed in a,
in a week.
Um,
is this one of those things though?
Cause I know like,
you know,
like
here I'll kill mine.
The animal planet does
have reenactments a lot.
Yeah.
They're not killed mine
and now yours works.
Yeah.
When I feel like restricts ips
on if my cables that whack.
But is it just a reenactment?
Is that,
it's like saying,
I know,
are they saying this is real footage
or are they just showing it to you?
But the show notes,
you want it
animal planet,
you know,
so you're watching this and you go,
Whoa,
okay,
so watch this.
Here we go.
North America.
What are you doing there?
Falling out of here.
Why'd you press a zoom in?
Then you fuck it was fucked up.
So,
okay,
you're looking at this right.
Cool place to them now
and you're going,
okay.
Um,
what am I saying here?
Is that a person you're like,
what is this?
This looks like real water.
Okay,
fuck is this,
it's a fake fucking mermaid was a hit of
his pod before they make an open water
crossing.
Look at this shit.
You're watching this
and you walk off stage.
He has him down into dark
water are feeding grounds.
It's kind of cool though.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
They really do have mermaids gather here.
Is this just trying to teach you
about the ocean if Merman sources.
Oh No.
See there's the big whale
shark that preys on them.
Sharp fucks up to as well.
And Look at the mermaid all freaked
out and Avatar like they're crazy.
X Ray eyes.
A shark is
a shark that eight Wales,
God damn mega dams a
shark that eight whales.
But look at that stupid
looking fake mermaid.
So this is on animal planet.
So it's just using the,
the Merman to teach you about stuff.
And like he just swimming around like,
look,
this is what a shark looks like.
If it eats a well,
that's it.
Learn something else today.
Yeah,
I guess I mean that,
that is exactly what it is.
What are they trying,
I don't know what they're
trying to do the same.
We'll have mermaids exist.
This is what they'd be like.
So we made a documentary.
Well we pretended that they were real
and we incorporated them into regular
world.
So like at one point in
time to where Mermaids,
so they're saying megalith don.
So the,
I guess what they're saying is,
let's pretend that back
when mega don was real,
there were also dolphins.
So you know what the problem is,
man,
the fossil record is kind of tricky
because everything doesn't leave a fossil.
So they could pretend that
there was some fucking mermaids.
Cause it's not like we combed every
inch of the ocean looking for fish bones
that also have people faces.
We haven't really been
looking for that shit.
So they came up with this stupid thing.
Get to get answers.
Yeah.
Like I don't know what they were
thinking when they put that together.
Yeah.
The,
it's a,
there's an article on Snoop's about it.
Snopes,
Snopes.
Snoops snoop.
Snoop sounds better than than Snopes.
Like I've been snooping around
and I found out the answers wrong.
Snopes like Oh snoot it
would've Snopes mean.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm right.
Maybe it's snoops.
I don't think it a person
who wants to build it.
How would they miss the Palette?
Fuck is wrong with you guys.
An idiot.
Silly that that Burbank
thing is so stupid.
Like I told you about this,
the rich guy that I know that has a,
he's,
he's a Merman.
He's trying,
he hasn't tried and he has actually has
a trident and his wife is a mermaid and
they have a fucking,
the whole like their their wall.
They have a monstrous house.
Okay.
It's guys like a multibillionaire and
they have this monstrous house where I'm
like one side like the entryway.
Like cause you enter into
the house as a mural.
Yeah,
he owns like some big companies,
man,
like haircare products or some shit.
That's hilarious.
He's a baller though.
Like old school.
My old time baller painting
himself on the wall.
I was like Greek.
My uncle,
my uncle and my aunt,
they have there so like a proper,
like they're very,
they,
their whole house is really decorated
nice and everything and they both have,
you know,
real jobs.
Like he's an accountant or
something like that and,
and,
but yet he has this taste for really
creepy artwork and like you go into each
room,
it's just a big one,
uh,
one with a big Bush hanging out like a
painting of a really beautiful painting.
But then like over there in their kitchen,
they have another pain where a woman
just sitting there with her butthole
exposed and it's just
like as a kid I was a kid,
I was always like,
what stuff?
Like my mom couldn't say like cover your
eyes cause every single room was that.
And then you go to the bathroom and I
remember being like a 10 year old or not
even that,
maybe an 11 year old and like going to
the bathroom in his magazines next to the
toilet,
we're all playboys.
I'm like,
I would go to the bathroom like 15
times a day and they just had an open,
it was awesome.
He is a freak.
They do as a freak and it's
always those accountant types,
you know,
they're all buttoned down and
shit and then they get home.
They're just staring
at but holds this look,
it's,
it's art.
It's art.
You could do anything.
It's like calling it art as long
as you like make it kind of crafty,
make it like shiny and slippery
and black and white and weird.
You know,
you can have a bottle.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
It's still above all.
If you're looking to beat off,
it's right there.
If you've ever seen doctor Kevorkian is,
aren't I pull it,
pull that
up.
Because that's when I turned
the corner on Doctor Kevorkian.
I thought like doctor Kevorkian.
I said,
well,
you know what?
This guy's very noble
and what he's doing is,
uh,
you know,
he's helping people that are terminally
ill and they're in constant pain and
he's,
uh,
he's giving them a noble way out.
And I think,
you know,
fuck the government.
If we're going after this guy and then
I saw some of his paintings and I was
like,
okay,
this guy is fuck,
ah man,
this guy is fucked up.
Kevorkian did some like dark shit.
Look at that picture.
Oh look at that picture.
He's got a guy who has no head.
Okay.
And he's got,
his head is on the table in a plate
with an apple and its mouth like a pig,
you know,
ping us an apple in his mouth.
So he's holding up a fork and
a knife while he's got no head.
And then behind him it's
like back back it up.
So everybody could say behind him it
looks like some Aztec warrior or something
like that it looks like.
Yeah,
like
yeah,
it's like a Roman or you know,
I guess it's supposed to represent that
someone did something horrendous to this
person is now propping them
up in jest or something.
I don't know what this is.
The road war helmet,
which is weird because this is like,
you know,
obviously from a different,
yeah,
different areas.
Bullets in this one.
There's like little bombs here and then
it looks like a bunch of crosses and
Jewish stars.
Maybe.
It's very weird.
Okay.
Stars.
He's,
he had a lot of very weird stuff.
Um,
and you just look at that and go,
okay,
like are you enjoying
killing these people?
Like you know,
like look at the,
pulled that one next to the skull.
You see the one next to the scope
to the one to the left of that?
Yeah.
The,
the one in the middle.
Yeah.
Wait these few that,
what's this like what is this guy saying?
What the fuck is this guy saying?
Brotherhood.
Yeah.
He's got like a vampire in the center.
It's a black guy and there's like a guy
who's wearing a suit and the the neck of
the suit is a vampire and
evil vampire and the wreck,
I mean it's like a DMT trip.
Yeah.
It's really weird.
Wow.
Look at this.
It's like some of it is kind of cool,
you know,
like the skull one in the middle
doesn't really freak me out.
I go,
okay,
well the guy dealt with death.
I mean that is a,
an accurate representation
of skull and some bones.
Nothing wrong with that,
but the guy eating his own fucking head,
you don't want to play like what is,
okay.
And what is the one to
the far right above there?
This one.
What's the one where it
looks like an old man?
This naked c the one.
Ah,
Shit.
Okay.
The One?
Yeah.
Up in the top and not next to that one.
This one?
Yeah.
What is that?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What does that,
oops.
All right.
Good outline that's going to show it.
Yeah.
What is this?
He's like showing someone dying.
It's called fever fever for the
flavor of a Pringles beaver for seven.
He could,
but he's got a guy
with holding an arm and
his body is breaking apart.
He's holding his own arm.
His body's breaking apart on him.
Wow.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
That's one of the ones that
I thought was really dark.
Like what's going on with that guy?
This Santa Claus is stepping on a baby.
Is that the scarecrow?
Yeah.
Santa Claus is stepping out.
What was that?
A pig.
Oh no,
that's the baby Jesus.
No.
What is that?
No,
it's baby [inaudible] baby.
[inaudible] Christ Jesus Christ.
Okay.
What the fuck this guy really did draw.
That is a baby.
He drew Santa Clauses boot
coming out of a chimney.
Squashing a baby.
First of all,
who the fuck puts a baby in a fireplace?
That's a manner baby.
Jesus manner.
But it's a fireplace and the
main church main drizen baby.
Jesus Jewish.
Why don't you let us
see the whole picture?
Pope making a full screen
because the resolutions.
Good.
Know that image.
What does that thing to the left?
That a scarecrow.
Yeah.
You can't draw boots.
Stepping on babies.
You fucking Weirdo.
Why are you drawing that?
See,
here's the rest of the
wise men up here going.
Where'd that baby go?
So it's a combination of Santa Claus and
wizard of Oz.
Like that's a Zombie.
What is that?
Is that a party hat on that motherfucker?
If a dunce hat,
is it a downside?
He was weird,
man.
He was a weird fuck that guy's
got a leaf over his dick though.
Good play could play Jackie,
that nobody wants to see
it die in Guy's Dick.
You could step on a baby
that's all well and good,
but put a leaf over his penis.
Like what is it?
What is he trying to say?
You know,
and in the clouds,
this killing religion.
Well,
when I saw some of that,
that's when I sort of turned
the corner on that cat.
I was like,
wow,
maybe there's more to the
story than meets the eye.
Maybe,
you know.
I was like,
well maybe this guy like met
somebody and it probably was that,
that saw somebody who
desperately needed help,
but maybe also on Gerard it a little bit,
you know,
it looks like he might've had a,
uh,
a taste for the McCobb.
Yeah.
I mean,
you pretty much draw what you like.
Yeah.
That's what you drew.
You always used to draw
monsters and stuff.
I used to draw boobs and eyeballs.
Yeah.
But the difference is I wasn't
killing people while I was doing it,
you know?
I mean,
I guess the guy has every right
to express himself like that,
but I was doing it because I loved monster
movies and I was 14 this guy's 80 and
he's a doctor who kills people and he's,
you know,
painting people with no heads.
I mean,
I guess he could do whatever you want.
It's just art,
right?
I mean,
what kind of a hypocrite would I be to
say that there's any difference between
what he's doing and what
Guillermo del Toro is doing?
He's just creating art.
This is his own art.
You know,
I don't think we're all,
the tour really believes this is some
fucking dead lady who lives in a cabin who
kills you in a,
raises your babies.
There's this really awesome artists
that just got turned onto names.
So eat milk and look at this.
This is just a painting
she did the other day,
but look how crazy it is.
It looks so realistic.
Like when people can paint,
I can get it.
Oh Great.
Here.
But like,
it's like her face,
he,
it's hard to get a close
up on these Twitter photos,
but see,
but I check it out on Twitter.
How do you know this person?
I just got turned onto her art and
that's how so you don't know or just know
over aren't yeah.
Alright.
And then Kelly tell anything.
Just look okay.
It looks like good stuff.
Yeah,
but I see tidies c to d.
Oh,
that's it.
Titties.
That's what it was today is a senior girl.
Yeah,
it was titties.
It was
a senior girl bottom.
I wasn't something on the Internet,
remember?
Cause it had something.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was part of it.
That was eventually two days,
two days.
I can see your girlfriends,
butthole girls on the Internet.
It was like you would,
you would show of us tits all the time.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
like you would like,
he would get pictures.
He was dating this girl that was like
a naked model and she would send them
pictures of tests and go look.
He just like stick them in your face.
And then I just started a song,
ted to Hays,
senior girl's butthole.
Oh God,
what should we can remember that?
Cause the real chorus was really catchy.
It was funny.
We were having fun.
We were baked and we were were goofing
around and somehow or another it became a
song that like repeated itself
like a couple of months.
I could see
a senior girls bottle
people at home ago.
No,
this is a classic example.
Well have you guys be in stone and think
something's funny when it actually is
not funny at all.
And to someone who is sober,
it's really annoying.
And that's what's annoying
about stone people.
God dammit.
That's what happens man.
People get all,
all agitated and shit agitated.
That's when they find they
find agitation and stoners,
Dana white has this thing
called McNear's disease.
Have you ever heard of that shit?
What's that?
I mean maybe I'm not spelling it.
E Er's disease.
Um,
it's spelled m e n.
I.
E.
R.
E McNear's disease.
And,
uh,
it has to do with,
um,
he had,
he got kind of fight once with a bunch
of dudes and they beat him up and fucked
up his ear and now he gets like vertigo
attacks and like ringing in his ear.
And you know what's a,
a,
a cure for this shit?
Marijuana.
That's right.
And as he tried,
does he did marijuana?
Of course.
Dot.
Has He ever done,
we're going to have to hotbox
this motherfucker today.
I think that's a great idea.
Do we have any more joints,
world?
Uh,
I might have one in my car car
and went out to go get that shit.
I can't even have one in my car.
I don't have my car here.
Fuck.
Well,
there's an ashtray.
There's at least 15 hits
here and he's asked Tracy,
we can make it happen.
We can hotbox him.
What about after a hot box and we
might change Danowitz life today.
What if we do one of
those things where like,
uh,
he,
he puts it,
I put it in his mouth and he
sucks on the other end of the day.
Hey Jesus Christ,
comma,
a,
you think he is?
What's that called?
It's called
putting it in my mouth and suck on this.
Like what are you even say what
time of it's been Doug Benson?
I was with Doug Benson
in this old Marin's,
like puts it in his mouth and told him
no shock box and old man and he did it?
No.
Okay.
Wow.
I forgot all about that.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
dogs are silly bitch.
I tweeted his picture,
I was in Utah and uh,
stopped in some best buy to pick up some
DVDs for the little ones so they can,
uh,
watch a Cinderella and shed cause you
get bored if you don't have like specific
shit that they enjoy.
So,
uh,
we,
I pulled in the spring and I saw Doug
Manson's picture and the comedy section.
It's kind of cool and you're
in the middle of nowhere.
You don't know anybody and you walk into
a store and you see your friend's face.
Ah,
I know that dude.
So I tweeted it right.
But I instagrammed it.
And when I instagrammed it,
you know how you put,
uh,
at Doug Benson will they cut out the
APP part when they poured it over from
Instagram to Twitter?
You know what that means?
That means they're a douchebag.
No,
it means that Doug Benson doesn't have
the name Doug Benson on Instagram.
Right.
You know who does another guy.
But there is a bug Benson on Instagram.
But the difference,
Oh Doug Benson on Twitter is different
so that when it goes to Twitter it's not
the same one.
So it doesn't give the
Hashtag confused people.
Okay,
that does make sense.
Actually.
That's actually a smart move.
But I,
you know,
I wanted it to be both Twitter and they
should give me that option if fucks.
It should be both because in,
in Instagram it goes to this other guy
and now I have to just say Doug Benson
and so I can't ever Instagram
and tweet something.
Right.
Because if my Instagram and tweet it,
then it leaves that part out.
Yeah.
It's one of their problems.
And that's because Instagram and Twitter
are two different companies so they
don't play rent long that nicely.
I think somebody needs to pony up the
Cheddar and come up with that Instagram
money's dog.
How much you think Instagram
is worth right now?
I don't know.
Billions.
Right.
Since vine came out,
I haven't used it once.
So Brian,
my own stock and vine.
No,
if I did I'd be rich as fuck.
Yeah,
I'm Matt Twitter.
Matt stags just brought
up vine to me today.
It's all the rage.
The kids are all talking about it.
Yeah but the problem is is that I find
myself vining cause I want to vine so
much cause I want to play around with
it and want to try things and do things.
But now I'm not like one of these guys
that sit there and do 30 takes trying to
make the perfect vine and that,
you know,
we don't have to.
I know you're okay now you
can become a competitive,
that's what it is.
You're seen other guys.
You're trying to get your shit and your
old video editing skills are coming
back.
Well,
I'm trying to be the best.
You tried to be the best at it.
Right?
Well listen man,
if you are a very talented video editor
and you don't do anything with it,
your videos that you did,
man,
when we were doing those
desk squad videos and we were
doing the Joe show videos,
you have some really
fucking cool video skills.
I can tell you what killed it.
I immediately tried know
the new final cut pro.
Really?
Yeah.
It's too hard.
No,
it's just the worst program in the road.
And I know I could buy old one,
but
whatever.
I don't feel like I just
annoyed the fuck out of me.
They,
it's so bad.
It's,
it's taking,
it's like if you ha if you were a painter,
it's taking all your,
uh,
brushes away and replacing
them with crayons.
Really.
That's how bad it really isn't.
You just go back to the old one.
Yeah.
But I think it's,
I mean,
they don't really upgrade
it or do anything.
I don't think they were,
I think they support it barely.
You know,
like I think I even have to uninstalling
my final cut pro that I have now.
Maybe before I could even put it on,
I heard that premiere pro is really good,
but [inaudible] approach so much money.
I tried to,
I was like,
how much is premiere pro buy it?
It was like $800 a month.
Listen,
I'll buy it if you want to use,
if you want to start making
videos again because you're,
you're really funny at it,
man.
I mean like look the buffer three 60.
If it wasn't for that video,
that dude would have never done that move.
You know?
I mean,
think about that.
The MNC a video.
Well,
there's also the whole fact that,
that now that we do podcasting,
it seems like there's nothing
that interesting anymore.
Like when we hang out were both just like,
uh,
hello.
You know what I do?
I couldn't barely muster
up the energy to do those,
uh,
getting on stage videos
where like backstage like,
Oh shit,
here we go.
Right.
But those are fun.
I like doing those because also they're
fun for me to step back and look.
Cause sometimes I can't really believe
how big some of those crowds are.
Like when you step back and
see the Chicago Theater or
Toronto and you look back
and you see 3,400 fucking people,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
this Anaheim one,
it's pretty big,
right?
Is it a big theater?
1300 people or something like that.
Yeah.
That's like,
that's a decent size.
But I'm like,
Chicago is really big.
Chicago is 3000 plus that
Vegas place was 3000.
There's a,
there's like,
you know,
those,
those big crowds or that's a
totally different kind of energy.
That's a weird feeling when you get
onstage and there's just this giant rush.
You've seen that Kevin Hart special,
the um,
the,
the commercial for his upcoming special.
Yeah,
dude,
he's on stage in front of like 18,000
people and the camera's behind him looking
at all these people like
screaming and cheering.
You're like,
whoa.
I think they had lighters up and shit too.
Yeah.
What's going on with the UFC video game?
I haven't.
Is that even,
is that dead now because
I know Thq is dead.
They just totally 100% bankrupt.
EA bought it.
He bought it through the UFC video.
Now if you heard anything
or are you going to be I'm
going through in her honor.
Oh,
I see.
I don't really want to do it
this other way for Dan showed up.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll wind up doing it.
I'm sure.
Probably.
Maybe not.
I don't want to.
Yay.
It's all fun dude.
Doing those.
I mean it'd be really cool pool boob
you go to full could sue the room and
actually do some walk.
You fucking pussy the,
but the,
the reality is it's not,
it's not a good time.
It's not like podcasting,
it's not like writing comedy.
It's not like doing all the things I enjoy
doing and it takes all lot of fucking
time that I don't have right now.
And that's,
that's the,
the real problem with
everything with this,
a new show that I can't really mention
that I'm putting together right now.
And then just writing comedy and
performing comedy and doing these,
I mean this is the fourth one of these
we did this week I didn't think were
going to do for,
I was trying to do three a week cause
I feel like three keeps me from getting
burnt out.
Yeah.
It's hard to talk.
Like on top of this,
I'm doing seven other ones and I'm,
I'm like dead.
Yeah.
Well that's your issue that inside you,
you,
you'd do it a little too much,
but you know,
it's your choice and it's also,
you know,
a side business sort of
thing you've got going on.
If I don't do it,
I probably would be
murdered at this point.
And also
we were talking about where,
you know,
we,
uh,
we have,
an interesting situation now with all
of these comedians that were sort of a
network together with,
and,
uh,
I think we,
we've found,
uh,
some unique ideas as to
how to like help everybody.
It's a matter of checking for
the light control stuck on green.
We're,
uh,
we have some unique opportunities to like,
do specials with people and Shit.
Like I liked how are he's doing his
special now and he's doing it online.
I would like to do one with Joey
and we'd like to do one with,
with you and I think we should
probably start doing those.
We were talking about
this before the podcast,
like doing them out of the ice house,
like doing special at the ice
house would be fucking awesome.
They already have like
one camera that's on you.
Like they film like they'll,
they'll give you a DVD of the set anyway.
Then then we just need like side angles,
you know,
set up cameras on the sides of the room.
Fillmont hire someone to slap it together.
We could and you get the
real club experience with,
as we were saying before,
the podcast started quite frankly,
is better than the theater experience.
The theater experiences bigger.
It's crazier.
It's like wow.
It was like wow,
look at all these people.
But
it's also really,
really important to actually be able
to feel the vibe of the audience very
accurately.
And when you're in a theater you kind
of get like you see the front row or two
and he's just that the noise and the
feeling of the room kind of just goes
upwards or something where
we're near a comedy club.
You can feel up this girl to the right of,
he was kind of irritated or you can feel
that if you're killing it on this side,
if theater,
it's really hard to judge that.
And judging timing is completely
different than timing in a cause.
You're laughs have to
kind of carry farther.
So your timing.
So timing is a little
different than the sound
carries different and the,
the ceiling is like way higher.
Like when you're,
you're dealing with a theater,
you're dealing with two floors.
Okay.
There's a balcony and some places
like think Chicago at three floors.
Yeah.
So you're dealing with three,
a three story indoor building
and this gigantic cavernous room.
It's just a completely
different experience to,
it's like the ice house.
It's like you could jump up and
touch the ceiling at any place.
Let's say Dennis.
Hey look,
they showed up.
All right.
Dana white just pulled in
with a big smile on his face.
All full of toxic gases
were alive.
We are,
uh,
Dennis here.
He's our
hand.
Shakings.
Yeah.
What's up buddy?
Don't worry about it man.
We've been talking shit
about all kinds of things.
Yeah.
There is no reason to live in Los
Angeles and make that commute every day.
If you have to do that commute every day,
you need to fucking move.
I'd kill myself.
There's a lot of people that do it.
I'd rather fucking die to that everyday.
I'm not kidding you,
man.
That was brutal.
It's unbelievable.
And it gets worse and worse every year.
I moved here in 94 and it was bad then,
but it's now,
it's insanity.
Never Bitch about Las
Vegas traffic ever again.
You know,
I don't ever experienced
that when I come here,
cause I know exactly where I got it going.
I don't ever,
oh,
this is why it's madness.
It's madness.
I left two hours ago.
Oh that's you got lucky.
You got lucky.
Mean seven o'clock.
You should,
if you left an hour before that,
you would have been even more.
Fuck,
this place is cool.
When did you like the Werewolf?
It's trippy.
Where'd you get that?
I just had it made a,
this guy pat McGee,
this a,
he does a special effort
to make a wearable.
It's American Werewolf in
London and this is the alien,
right?
You gotta get the alien and Predator.
Yeah,
he's going to make me an a,
an alien to me.
Does that as well?
Yeah.
Pat Mcgee is this guy.
So special effects dude.
And that he's one of the things he does,
he makes,
he's uh,
he's made like 70 of these.
Okay.
70 people out there with
these fucking things.
It's crazy.
Giant American Werewolf.
I'm a grown up child,
Dana.
I know.
What I love about what
I love about you too.
Dana and I have known each
other for what do we mean?
Like 2001 or something like that.
I came down to watch the UFC
and we started talking shit.
And that was back when you guys had
just taken over the company and you were
just sort of trying to figure out what
the fuck was going on with this thing.
It's so funny to see.
It's like very rare in life that you get
a chance to see like some people buy a
sport like literally by the whole sport.
I mean there was nothing
going on Ms Pride in Japan,
but I in America there's not.
You bought the sport and then it became
gigantic all over the course of like a
decade or so.
Like when has that ever happened?
Not with skateboarding
that with motorcross,
not with soccer,
not with,
they tried with a million
different fucking things.
Nothing has ever gone from
being like a spectacle.
Like the first event I worked was Dothan,
Alabama,
UFC 12 1997 that was with seg.
We were in a fucking like
auditorium somewhere.
It was like maybe a thousand people
scattered in a 2000 seat place.
Right.
And it was,
it was a little tiny fucking airport.
You fly in and a propeller plane.
It was ridiculous.
Right to go from when,
when,
when people,
you know,
when people talk to me and they say,
you know what,
I see shit on the Internet,
or I read stuff on Twitter and like,
yeah,
these fucking guys are
in it for the money.
It's all about the money
and the this and that.
We'd tell you what,
when we've
fucking bought this thing in 2001
the Fertittas own station casinos,
the fourth largest gaming
company in the country,
they own Gordon Beers brewing company.
They sold it.
They've owned fuck real estate aim,
you name it.
These guys have had their
hands in everything they've,
they've bought and sold just about
everything and major stocks and all these
deals and shit.
When I talked him into
buying this company,
dude,
the guys that work for them,
you know,
there's,
there's an army of guys that work for
them to do all the finance and shit.
Thought this was the dumbest fucking
idea and the history of the world.
I remember they hated,
hated me,
hated the fucking UFC.
We're the redheaded stepchild
of the Fertitta portfolio.
You know,
I remember when the Vladimir,
Matt,
you Shanko Tito Ortiz fight went over
and I wasn't working for you guys back
then.
I was a,
I was a spectator and it was right
after September 11th and it was fucking
really dramatic.
I mean,
Tito was standing there and he had the
American flag in his hand and people went
fucking crazy
room.
If you remember at that
time when that happened,
it was two weeks after
September 11 and we uh,
we actually sold out Mandalay bay.
Um,
it was already sold out,
but we didn't know if anybody's
going to fucking show up,
you know what I mean?
Because number 11,
nobody was flying plates.
I'm not kidding you.
Las Vegas was a ghost town.
You could fucking run
through a casino naked.
Nobody would see you.
It was dead and a real weird
eerie time fucking everybody got,
everybody came to Las
Vegas for that event,
man.
It was like the first big event back in
Vegas after all the shit happened for
that event.
I wasn't working for you
guys and Camry quite suck.
Every fight suck.
And then we went over on
the fucking paper view.
Yeah,
you guys didn't have it down yet.
I'm a pretty upbeat person.
I'm don't get depressed
and I'll get fucked.
I seriously was thinking
about fucking killing myself.
Then
I went and I hung out with
you guys after it was over.
It was you and Lorenzo and you just both
the after party was like the shittiest
after party ever.
You were like,
we have to give everybody
their money back.
Like whoa.
So you guys,
it got to this point where
you're thinking about selling.
That's why people don't want
to hear something funny.
People always ask me
why I don't do the uh,
the fucking,
what's it called?
The Star spangled banner,
you know?
Yeah.
What is that one is?
Why?
Why I don't do that.
We did it that night.
We did it that night and I
completely fucking blame that.
That was why it happened.
You had to Dover
just September 11.
Right?
There was like a crazy
energy in the air that night.
It was a,
it was really intense when Tito made
this like big dramatic entrance.
That was back when you guys still have
the ramp and Tito's at the top of the
ramp.
And I don't know if there's pyrotechnics.
I don't remember the fucking man.
Hello half the building up back then.
You didn't have like a half the place.
I was so happy when you
guys stopped doing that.
Tito on fire and fucking uh,
and the metal literally
caught on fire.
Guys have gotten lit on fire,
man.
You know why we did that?
Nobody.
That's why we did that.
Why we did that big stage.
Why ramp and all the pyrotechnics.
Why?
Because we didn't sell that
many tickets back then.
Oh see eight up super cut off the ramp,
cut off a quarter of the building
and make it look like the place.
Then we'll go and pride
did it like as a pageant.
She thing pride had
some amazing entrances,
but they lit Joelle
deal all of air on fire,
you know,
and then to bring them down.
If I'm not joking,
I believe it was like you don't fight.
I believe it.
It's,
that's a dangerous thing.
Fucking pyrotechnics and shit and yeah,
it's not necessary.
I don't like mixing place.
Look full back then though.
You had to take up a quarter of the arena
and then you got less tickets to sell.
My favorite walk in is Frankie Edgar
cause when they let that motherfucker
Biggie don't,
don't,
he just starts running.
He just runs.
Let me tell you how much better I
like guys coming out of tunnels.
You know,
we did what we had to do in the
beginning with this thing and,
and there was a lot of smoke and mirrors
and stuff that you have to do to,
to make something like this
happening and to grow it.
Um,
but for me,
I'm a hardcore traditional fucking toe.
The bone fight fan.
I want to see a dude coming out of the
bowels of the fucking arena through a
tunnel and through a crowd of arms and
hands sticking out and people going
crazy.
I love that shit.
Yeah,
me too.
Nick the to sit down
and you fucking nervous.
Prick.
What are you doing?
You're wandering around back there.
Hold it under your date and
meet the whole couch here fella.
You've been sucking in gas
fumes for an hour and a half.
Oh No.
Pocket.
He's been sleeping for fucking
11 hours so you can easily,
he's now,
he's all wired and ready to
fucking roll if you've never seen.
Dana has he's world famous
video blogs where there's no,
no president of any company
that lets people in.
And as much as you let people,
you do these video blogs
where occasionally some
ridiculous things take place.
And one of them was a,
our good pal Joe Lozan and nick the tooth,
a grappling competition.
He gave Joe Lowe's on $1,000 for every
submission that he could pull off in five
minutes,
bad move.
And he put a six and six
submission beaten down,
you know.
And,
and nick was like,
Hey,
I believe tap.
I mean he's a fucking
professional fighter.
Like,
what are you talking about?
The people are so ridiculous when it
comes to like professional fighters.
Do you know how many people ask me?
They're like,
you get these,
these fucking guys who think,
you know,
really don't get and appreciate how good
these fighters really are and what to
be a mixed martial artist really means.
And now I've got these guys
saying they fucking crazy.
You were actually think that Ronda
Rousey could fucking do something.
Oh my fucking God.
Do you know him?
Do you know what she did to
that boxer that I saw it.
I watched them silly bitch.
Next is a beast.
She's 150 pound beast.
Okay,
she cut.
Wait to make one 3,550.
Did you see the sign woman of that
reporter guy supposed to be reviewed some
fucking dude with a camcorder.
He showed up with a g and was,
uh,
an asked,
you know,
he said,
this is a couple of days
ago before fight and she's,
he says,
well,
you know,
I don't think girls really
are that tough and this,
that and everything else.
What would it take to get you to throw me?
She goes,
you said the right things already,
buddy.
Let's do this.
She grabbed him by his fucking gay,
and I'm telling you,
the judo shit scares me man.
When when they take your feet,
go up in the air over and she could tell
she was using her fucking weight and
she came down on that dude hard.
She fucked him up.
I'm sure man.
Yeah,
you don't want to lock
horns with an Olympian,
you know?
And it's the idea that's so stupid.
I've heard people say silly
shit about her like that.
She's,
Oh,
she's a woman.
I wouldn't be scaled.
She'll break your fucking
arm nice and your neck.
You don't know how,
like when you see like how quick
her hips move when she hits armbars,
that's some really high level shit.
When she whips those hips over,
like the amount of time you
have to recognize what she's
doing and the amount of
control she has and the ability to adjust
while you're realizing she's doing,
she knows what you're going to do.
She's done that a million
fucking times row.
So she knows that she's
throwing those things up.
You're going to try to pull out.
So she's going to scoot forward and she's
gonna catch you and belly down on you
and snap your shit son.
And she's got a fucking neck,
right?
And she's got fuck and she had beautiful
shoulder and she's still beautiful.
She's still a woman,
but she's about as like fit and strong.
Oh,
it's Aaron True Guy Right here.
Aaron is so silly.
He does this everywhere.
I told the guy,
yeah,
yeah.
I told them to stop doing this because
he's letting guys beat him up like,
like Jason Ellis beat the shit out of him,
man.
He beat the Shit Outta him.
He might fucking change
his mind after this.
Oh,
she did it on a hardwood.
Oh my God.
That's nothing,
Bro.
Wait till she throws him.
Oh No,
she does.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
this she does.
It's so easy to freeze up.
Watch when she lands on boom.
Oh.
[inaudible] ribs all on this side.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Erin has a Cyborg.
Beat the shit out of him.
He's had a lot of people
beat the shit out of him.
Look at his face,
man.
That's not fun.
Yeah,
that's so stupid.
But he,
he always does this.
He actually asked for it.
He's doing like a jackass sort of a thing.
That's a good way to get that
guy in about eight years.
See how he's feeling.
Especially he's not even doing a mat.
He's doing it on like a dance floor.
I was doing it for nothing.
I like you're fucking fighting and
trying to be the best and getting paid.
He's not doing it for nothing
because we're talking about him.
Yeah.
That's what he's trying to do.
It's going in a jackass style.
Listen,
what's his name?
Aaron.
True.
Erin true.
I hope you make a million fucking
dollars off off this podcast.
Okay,
good.
I hope so buddy.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Yeah.
I wouldn't let that happen.
He lets a lot of people beat him up.
He lets,
uh,
like I said,
he led a,
if you watch the Jason Ellis one,
that's the worst one.
LSP thought shit out of him.
He liked sparred with Jason and
Jason just started wailing on
full blast power shots to the head.
He was like,
yeah,
it wasn't right after that
for a couple of weeks.
I'm like,
yeah,
no kidding.
That's a good cushion.
It's called brain damage.
Dude.
What the fuck are you doing with yourself?
Are you out of your mind?
Speaking of brain damage,
did you know that your money's disease,
that,
uh,
that cannabis is like
one of the best cures?
Because I shot,
I did not know that.
He's not for you.
It's actually been doing a
lot of research for me on,
on the money's thing.
They actually found some shit,
you know,
I'm seeing all these doctors and stuff
and nick will tell folks who don't know
what we're talking about.
You've had this issue for me.
How many years now?
So what happened was
when I was 21 years old,
uh,
I lived in Boston and I,
I got jumped one night at this,
at this bar,
and these dudes beat the living shit
out of me for about a good 20 minutes,
20 minutes,
literally until the police came.
And,
uh,
at one point I remember I was on one knee,
it's fucking guy must have punched
me in this ear a thousand times,
you know,
and I was getting kicked and hit from
all kinds of different directions.
They're,
the guys were from Charlestown.
I'm lucky I didn't get stabbed.
I'm lucky I got the shit beat out of me.
So after that happened,
my ear rang for months,
I mean fucking loud to where I
couldn't sleep and stuff like that.
So I went to the doctor and they said,
you have permanent hearing loss and
damage to that year and everything else.
So no big deal,
you know,
it was what it was.
And I,
uh,
you know,
later on in life it,
and it eventually turned into minis,
which is nerve damage.
And the brain is telling the nervous,
telling the brain we're
moving when we're really not.
And it causes,
when I say spin man,
the room starts spinning so fast.
You have to grab on to shit.
You closed your eyes,
you go in the dark and just close
your eyes sometimes for hours.
You know,
when this thing hits me,
I'm down for sometimes
eight or nine hours.
And uh,
so there's no cure for it,
but they have these real controversial
surgeries that you can go in and do.
And you know,
I'm a fucking lunatic.
So I'm like,
I don't give a shit.
I'm getting the surgery,
Dah,
Dah.
And the doctor was kind of
hemming and hawing on it.
I said,
just do it doc.
Well,
I just went in yesterday.
You didn't,
you didn't know this cause we
didn't talk about this yet.
So this was my first followup and the
fucking surgery was a complete disaster.
So that's why I've been
so fucked up lately.
Disastrous.
Um,
it,
uh,
it helped 70% of the people,
it helps,
um,
the 30% that went the other way.
So now I have almost completely
lost the hearing in this ear.
My hearing is almost completely gone
and I've been having attacks every day.
The last two days I haven't had an attack.
So it's been pretty cool.
And,
uh,
I'm feeling pretty good.
But like I said,
so that's,
that's the,
in a nutshell,
there's nothing you can do about it unless
now I optical in and get the surgery
where they cut the nerve,
which will put me in the hospital for
seven days and then I'll have to learn how
to walk again.
So for how long,
how long does it take to learn
how to walk in and left the reds?
Lorenzo said his dad learned
to walk again in a month.
So in his dad was in his
sixties when he did it.
He had the same operation.
Yeah.
Whoa.
So
I,
I don't know,
a month.
A month of not knowing how to walk.
Yeah.
And then that perception,
like picking things up like this.
Whoa.
Yeah.
People don't realize how much the
ear is related to equilibrium.
It's why when guys get punched
sometimes you see in a fight or kicked.
Yeah,
they,
they get,
yeah,
they equilibrium blows and it's an,
it's an ear injury and inner ear injury
and sometimes eardrums get popped.
They get blown out from punches.
Especially,
you see that a lot.
In the old days,
guys would slap guys in the ears a
lot when they'd have them on the side,
they would slap them,
you know,
instead of punching them and you know,
it hurts like hell fuck.
Yeah.
Does a lot of guys have broken their
hands ground and pounded on dudes?
Because the fucking skull
is stronger than the knock.
All though the reality is,
and one of the things about boxing gloves,
his boxing,
those actually help protect your hand.
Look how many guys break their
hands in boxing by hitting.
Yeah,
Floyd breaks.
It's unbelievable.
But there isn't a lot
more hand damage in MMA.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean,
well there is a lot though.
If you really stop and think about
how many guys break their hands,
it's pretty extraordinary that the
point Floyd's hands were so bad.
It was looked like he was
going to have to retire one.
Yeah.
What did he want to doing about raising?
Yeah,
you got some crazy good surgeons.
Got little tiny hands.
It's weird.
Oh,
he's a tiny guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
anybody who's ever met Floyd on TV,
everybody looks bad.
He's tiny.
Yeah.
But his,
uh,
he has to,
he was using special gloves for a while
and he's pulling his punches and just,
just outbox and guys and Pitty Pat Numb,
you know,
he was breaking his hands
like crazy for a while.
Right.
Oh,
speaking of that,
have you seen this kid?
We didn't talk about this kid yet.
The fuck's his name?
Adrian Broner runner.
Yeah.
God Damn,
that kid's good.
I like him a lot.
The whole shtick he's got
going on as fucking stupid.
You know,
he's combing his hair
and fucking acting like,
dude,
nobody could be that fucking obnoxious.
Nobody would hang out with
the guy ever who you are.
He's just trying to get attention.
I know,
but he's still good.
Yeah.
He doesn't need it.
[inaudible] good man.
It's like Floyd's brilliant.
You know,
he goes,
tries to finish.
It's very dangerous.
Very dangerous.
How about this kid Reese from
fucking England at Farnam?
Yeah.
Tough,
tough calls them that,
that I brought a pop gun to a gun fight.
Yeah.
That was the problem.
He couldn't sing them.
The other thing too is,
you know,
I've always been critical of
the European boxing style.
That dude can box.
Yeah.
Reese can read Bob Man.
He's got great boxing skills and he uh,
and you know,
he hits hard to,
he hit Brian or with some shots he did
and he really sharpened up his head
movement for that fight.
They said that that was the start.
That was going to be the big issue,
but he was still stiff,
but he's like,
no,
no.
For this guy,
I'm going to move a lot.
Yeah.
What a talented guy,
man.
He look good.
Yeah.
Broner is amazing,
man.
He's a,
he's exciting and he's
going to move up to one 40,
hopefully.
And uh,
all a lot of good fights
for him at one 41 35.
It's like,
it's pretty much cleaned it out already.
Why Floyd went to showtime?
You think so?
Because of Brona I don't know.
He's just,
who's it going to fight over there?
Well,
I mean it's a Floyd.
Well Floyd's one 47.
I mean basically if Broner can run
one 40 and you can make one for you.
Yeah,
he's a big kid.
Won't be till so muscular,
you know,
fucking common nations that kid throws,
they're awesome.
Half half is like half the
amount of time they take to land.
Five,
six punches.
Madison fast.
I mean,
I think right now Floyd's probably
his boxing is just like a little bit,
probably a little too sharp,
a little too clean.
And other times that Reese popped him,
what would Floyd do?
And Floyd be able to shut them down.
But true Broner can put together
combinations like Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
The combinations that he landed on recent,
like the second and third.
It's like Jesus.
Unbelievable combinations
like ruthless speed.
Love it.
I love one is great fights,
man.
I love fights.
I love when there's a new
guy that raises the bar.
I stayed up and England til five
in the morning to watch that fight.
Oh really?
I was in the UK for the,
for the Wembley fight.
Whenever a guy comes along like a Roy
Jones Jr when he was in his prime or like
an Anderson Silva is right now.
A lot of it,
it's so fun to watch a guy
that's just like almost,
it feels like untouchable.
He just like,
wow,
what's going to happen here?
Like what is,
what's going to happen with this puzzle?
Anderson?
So fucking fun to watch.
I dread the day that dude retires.
I used to think that Roy
Jones jr did some crazy shit.
Like we would put his hand behind
his back and then knock somebody out.
But what he wouldn't do it standing
with his back to a cage and let it got,
come on.
Come on.
Waste 205 pounds and is on steroids.
Fucking take shots out of,
how about that,
right?
Yeah.
And then blast them and drop them
with like a perfectly placed knee
if you knew how,
you know.
Um,
Bonner flew home with me after
that cause he was having a baby.
If you knew how freaked
out he was by that fight.
The fight just fucking,
he's like,
that dude lives in the
matrix that dude lives.
And he says,
nobody's ever done that to me before.
I mean,
he just treated me like I was nothing
and I've never fought before and he was
fucking tripping.
It was a trippy fine.
It was trippy to watch,
especially considering that it's like
way above his weight class and he
manhandled Bonner when,
when,
when they got in a clinch,
she tripped him and then he just
perfectly timed bond or stand up.
And as soon as the,
or stood up,
boom,
blasted him in the solar plexus.
I mean,
he was like getting shot by a
cannon and he just went down.
When was the last time a guy went down
with the need of the body like that
before?
Yeah.
And No.
I mean,
that was,
yeah,
like he got shot.
I mean,
that's what he does when he throws
that man manager ruins people.
Yeah.
I mean,
look at the,
it's the same way when he
was being rich Franklin.
Uh,
you know,
grabbing that Clinton was just
phenomenal.
Man.
The guy is just an amazing fighter
and he's in his prime right now.
He's like,
got that perfect combination of
confidence and experience and success.
Yeah.
He's insight has own right now to
make him and fucking Jones happened.
Man.
I have to make that fight happen.
Do you think the one finance
talking about going to one 70,
right?
He's talking about going to one side.
What,
what,
what Anderson's talking about what
we're Anderson really talks about.
You fucks with the media a lot.
What do you really talks about?
His big fights.
He wants big fights,
you know?
Um,
so he's got
to walk this fine line.
We're probably going to do a
10 fight deal with this guy,
which is amazing.
Um,
he's going to be 38 and
to have them under it,
another 10 fights.
God,
I hope this guy fights 10 more times.
You know,
I hope it's possible.
Yeah.
I love,
I just,
you know,
it's like when I saw this Broner kid
and like when you see somebody that's
special,
the guys that really got
something really special,
it's just Anderson Silva's
fucking unbelievable.
He is unbelievable.
And you'd go,
man,
why was he going to keep that up?
But then you look at Herschel Walker,
Herschel Walker is like almost 50
years old and he's fucking shredded,
right?
I mean,
he looks amazing.
He does.
And they said that Hershel Walker was
training with like young football players
and he was out running them out,
conditioning them.
I mean like,
people are like going,
what the fuck is going on?
He's almost 50 years old.
And then Bernard Hopkins,
he's fighting for the
light heavyweight title.
He's 48 48 fucking years old.
Hock Hopkins is shocking,
especially in boxing and
everyone's like that.
But you know,
I'm pretty sure Hopkins was in jail
early on in his career for a while.
So he had a big layoff
early when he was young,
you know,
and always took care of himself.
Stayed in shape.
No drugs,
no alcohol,
no bolts.
Makes it makes a big difference.
Yeah.
The discipline.
He's never out of shape,
so he never allows himself to have to
work back to get their party and kills
fighters.
Kels Amanda's,
I saw it happen to chuck.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
We've seen so many guys like that.
They're just,
they get so crazy with the success and
they so crazy with the buzzy fucking king
of the world.
It's so hard,
so hard to do the whole,
the whole chocolate Dell era when
when chuck beat Tito that night,
it's just fucking,
it was crazy,
man.
You know,
I didn't bend together since,
since 1997 or something like that.
98 maybe.
And then to see that fucking explosion
and just how this dude became so huge,
like after his fights,
everybody wanted a piece of that guy.
It was insane.
It was fucking insane,
man.
I've never seen anything like it.
Yeah.
He rode like a wild,
crazy wave for like four or
five years and then just like,
all right,
now it's like,
now he's like back to
being a normal dude again.
Yeah.
It's really sad.
He's completely fucking normal.
And which is good.
I'm happy,
man.
Yeah,
he did it.
He got fucking crazy when it was time to
get crazy and then he settled down and
very impressive.
It makes me wonder if he
hadn't partied how much,
how much longer he could have stayed.
But you know what?
That dude made so much fucking money and,
and you know he's,
he said he's good.
It was also his style.
His style was so aggressive.
Yeah.
He was such a destroyer that like
that style you put yourself in danger.
And it was also that he had
this incredible Chin and
he had this willingness to
trade.
Yup.
He would,
he would get in there and he had the will,
he would,
he would eat one to give one.
And that's what made him so perfect too,
for the time we were coming
up.
Because you had all these guys that
understood boxing and not a lot of people
understood the ground game.
And that was what people loved about this
guy who's a fucking warhorse who just
moved forward,
you know,
an eat shots to give,
he'd take three to give
you that one fucking,
you know,
boom.
And it was at a time where a lot
of people thought the ground part.
Like if there weren't like
really good practitioners,
like some people an into the ground part,
they would have like blue.
We'll chuck was the best guy at avoiding
it and the best guide getting back up
when he would hit the ground,
he had bullied immediately
explode with under hooks,
scoot his hips back.
He would be up quicker than anybody.
And even if you took him down,
except Randy ran was
the only guy that ever,
that was able to take them
down to hold them down.
But that was when chuck,
you didn't,
he didn't take that fight seriously.
Now
Dude,
I'll never forget that.
As long as I fucking live the
night before he fako tour,
it's like two 30 in the morning at the
hard rock and I'm walking through the
hard rock and he's fucking
there at the hard rock.
I go,
what the fuck are you doing?
Why?
Why are you here?
How do Doug's Road?
But I can worry about it.
I'm done.
You know what I'm doing?
I said,
dude,
get your fucking punk
ass home and go to bed.
Are you fucking crazy?
You know what I mean?
It was just such a given that
he was going to win this fight.
Wow.
And you know,
I've seen that.
I've seen guys that were fighting where
I ran into him at three o'clock in the
morning.
I ran into Ken shamrock in a diner.
It was 3:30 AM in Florida when
he was going to fight Tito.
He was gonna Fight Tito at the hard rock.
Right.
I remember that.
That was a big fight.
It was like three 30 in the morning
and we were getting breakfast and a,
and Ken walked in,
I'm like,
aren't you fighting today?
And uh,
he was just all smiles.
He,
that was the one
that was the one that I had to do for
free because the paper view one sucks so
bad.
Remember they fought and the paper
view and then the ref jumped in.
And stop it and Ken jump right back up.
Like,
what the fuck stopped that fight?
I was still in this thing,
you know?
That's fine.
I did the fight again for free at
the hard rock and we put it on spike.
That's right.
3:30 AM he was getting
breakfast is hanging out.
I was like,
you're not in bed yet.
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
yeah.
Well,
it showed
Ken hit a point in his career
where he was just sorta cashing it.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
I mean,
he was unbelievably
ferocious in his early days.
You know,
you'd go back and you watch,
uh,
like,
some of his early fights.
I mean,
you say he was a fucking animal.
He went after it.
But then after awhile it's like,
how many times can you do that?
You know,
how many times can you have those,
those brutal fights over and over again?
Those fights that he had over.
And Pride too.
It's like after a while it's like there's,
there's not much left.
You got a catch him.
I agree.
When you see guys like Dan Severen and
he seemed like Dan was like recently
retired,
right?
I mean,
how old is he now?
He's in his fifties he's
in his 50s you know,
that's one of the weirdest
aspects of the fight game.
Like you tell a guy to stop,
but you look at a guy like him though,
he's just such a fucking competitor.
Has Been,
was a wrestler.
Yeah.
These wrestlers are fucking tough man.
And uh,
you know,
as crazy as it is,
I respect the guy.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
But I respect him.
Well,
he was doing his own thing.
I'm telling you.
And you know that she'd been
around the game long enough.
These dudes were fucking born to do this.
The guys who fight,
we're put on this fucking earth
and they weren't fighting.
They'd be fucking some shit up somewhere.
You know what I mean?
It would be scary if,
imagine you get some of these broader,
you,
he gets some of these
fucking freaks out there.
It's like that want to try to control
people's lives and tell them what they can
do and people shouldn't be fighting.
And people shut the fuck people
shouldn't be playing golf asshole.
You know what I mean?
That's what I think.
So does that really mean people
shouldn't be playing fucking golf?
No.
Well,
I think the idea that they're saying
by saying that people shouldn't be
fighting,
is it?
You're encouraging something that's a
antisocial behavior or something that's a
bit and contrary to the
way we want society to be.
You want to see antisocial behavior,
make it so these guys
can't fucking fights.
Maybe.
So there's no outlet.
Maybe what happens time down
and make them watch opera.
They'll go get the hook out on you.
Never fucking that.
I Ran Barkley.
Yeah.
Some after some fight I ran Barkley,
the guy asked him,
said,
so if you weren't fighting,
what would you be doing?
He said,
that'd be robbing your house right now.
You know?
And those dudes were fucking serious.
I mean if you ask those guys in boxing,
some of the guys from the old days,
it came from boxing,
they'd be fucking dead or in
jail or doing something bad.
You know,
boxing in a lot of other combat sports
has taken people out of the streets and
fucking dude,
me and Mike Tyson have
talked about this for hours,
for fucking hours about it.
He talks about what he would have
been doing if he didn't fucking,
if,
if he at first of all he didn't hook up
with cuffs and he didn't go up there and
any and he didn't,
he said cusp broke me down as a fucking
human being and then built me back up
and he said,
I honestly truly believe that me and him
were put together cause he's the only
one that could have fucking
done it because let me tell
you what I would've been
doing if I didn't meet costs
and I didn't get into boxing.
Yeah.
He had so much respect
for that guy as a trainer.
And so much respect for him as a father
figure that they look inspired him to
greatness and inspired him to focus a
hundred percent on pleasing that guy
because that was the first guy to really
show them love and to really show him
respect and to have,
have faith in him and then under him,
all of a sudden,
all these great things are happening,
all the successes happening.
So it reinforced his love for him.
Annie talked about how much fucking
anger he had inside of him at that time.
He had a lot of anger that needed to be,
uh,
you know,
expressed.
Yes.
Well,
do you watch those combinations?
See throws when he's training
with cost is a video of him,
I think.
I think it's,
I don't know if it's Kevin Rooney or
teddy atlas or who's working with them,
but he's thrown off combinations on the
bag and he's probably like 18 years old
and it's like,
and you're just watching
the sec ridiculous,
ruthless,
violent combinations like no
one has ever thrown before.
I don't give a fuck about Joe Louis.
Muhammad Ali was the greatest.
Yes,
a great cultural figure.
A great boxer for his era.
I think Mike Tyson was the
greatest freak that's ever existed.
I don't think it's ever
been anybody like that.
I agree.
The Marvis Frazier fight,
you remember that fine.
Jesus Christ.
And that was as close to a murder as
you could watch on television when you
start to watch stuff
for old fights at Tyson coming up,
there's guys that he just,
Ooh,
fucking murder murder Frank
Bruno fight just loved him.
And the,
at the,
at the time when I was first coming up,
you know,
and,
and in boxing right,
there was a gym called golden gloves and
golden gloves was the first gym that I
worked out of the Vegas.
And uh,
they used to shut the place down
from Mike when Mike would come in.
Right.
So He'd come in and train their be fucking
50 brand new cars that would pull in
the fucking park.
It was right,
dude.
It was craziness.
The aura that surrounded Tyson at that
time and just all the crazy shit that
went on.
But Tigers.
Yeah,
tigers Everlast made
a special bag for him,
so they'd come in and take down
the bags in the fucking gym,
the real bags,
and they'd put up these special
bags that were fucking this big.
They were just massive.
You couldn't put your arms around them
right when he would hit a regular fucking
bag that you would buy.
You know when you break
a firecracker and half,
that's what the fucking bag would
look like when he would hit it.
The fucking thing would snap in half
this way and come back this way.
The fucking power that this guy had when
he punched you had to be there to see
it in person to really believe it.
Like you said,
the combination.
Do you see him throwing in the bag
and just if when you saw it in person,
you were just like,
what?
I love to see that in person.
You need to see what you have to do is
you have to go see his fucking standup.
Show me,
bro.
If you even remotely like
Tyson back in the day,
the Mitch Blood Green Story that he tells,
I'm not gonna fuck with it.
Cause if you got to see Tyson,
tell it it now is awesome.
He's,
he just,
he's on tour,
right?
He just called me today.
He's,
he's got a reality show.
What?
So he asked me to be in this reality show.
Oh my God.
So I start filming his reality
show with them like next week.
Oh my God.
The
odd couple is my container.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's not just me and him.
It just fucking doing a cameo or
so I don't what he wants from me,
but every time he asked
me to do them a favor,
I'm like,
dude,
I do anything.
This isn't a weird on my cousin calls.
Yeah.
And do you look at your phone and go,
Holy Shit,
Mike Tyson's corner.
I fucking Dude Tyson is
my favorite all time.
You know,
I fucking love Mike.
He's one of my favorite
all time fighters as well.
There was nothing like a Tyson fight.
Yeah,
exactly.
What different.
They were different experiences.
So true.
You know when you saw him fight
somebody like Jesus Christ,
how's Tony Tub's going to do
to him when you're watching,
I'll give a fuck if you are there live.
Which I was very lucky
that I was able to do that.
You know,
go
to a few Mike Tyson fights live when he
fought or if you were sitting at home
watching TV.
As soon as they fucking showed
him on camera walking out,
you just fucking got
the goosebumps and went,
oh my God.
He was a terrible
fine.
I love that scene in the movie Tyson
where he talks about what's going through
his mind.
All his insecurities go away.
By the time he gets to the cane where
he got Tommy gets in the ring rather.
Yeah.
That is such a great with the way
he's talking through it there.
I'm a God.
I'm in
dark.
The bowl,
there's nothing,
there's nothing.
I mean,
when you watch a Tyson documentary,
it's fucking awesome.
You just,
you're an awe.
I just,
yeah,
it was a completely different cultural
experience than like the Muhammad Ali era
must've been because the Muhammad Ali
thing was like Muhammad Ali was different
because he was so much more
admirable as a human being.
Like what he did was like
during the Vietnam War,
he said,
you know what man?
Why are we going to war?
Why?
Why do you,
why are you sending me to war?
Well,
I don't want to kill no Viet Cong.
No Viet Cong never did anyway.
And then everybody in America was like,
yeah,
what the fuck is going on?
What are you doing?
And then they took is,
I mean they made a martyr out of him by
taking his career away for three years.
So when you see like Muhammad Ali,
you see a different thing.
You see like a troubled time.
The Nixon administration and people were
down on the government and the Vietnam
War was so unpopular.
When you see Mike Tyson,
you just saw destruction.
It was a completely different experience.
It's like he was like
Sonny Liston on meth.
It was like Sonny Liston.
But moving a hundred miles an hour and
there was no Muhammad Ali to stop him.
There was no Muhammad Ali to,
you know,
no young,
brash kid to be thrown in with boxing.
I always talk about when,
when,
when I'm talking about the UFC to two
people who really don't understand
fighting in the sport and stuff with that.
So the way that I usually
break it down for them,
as I say,
listen,
you look at the NFL,
how big the NFL is been
trying to go over here,
go over there.
Crickets big over there and
every big over here fighting,
you know,
crosses all cultural and
language barriers and shit.
No matter what color you are,
what country you come from,
what language speak,
we're human beings and
findings in our fucking DNA.
What really,
you know,
when you really think about
fucking all the most famous guys,
think about Michael Jordan,
how big he is.
You know,
people know Michael Jordan
and some parts of the world,
Gretzky,
Eh,
here and there.
You think of all the grades.
Think about who are really
fucking well known everywhere,
all of the fucking planet.
And worshipped guys like fucking Tyson.
You know what I mean?
Muhammad Ali,
Bruce Lee
Klitschko.
That motherfucker gets on a plane.
Nobody even pays attention to him,
right?
I was on a plane with him
and my friend was like,
who's that fucking giant?
I go,
dude,
that's the heavyweight
boxing champion the world.
So he goes,
the heavyweight boxing
champion is a white guy.
I go,
yeah,
it's a white Russian guy.
He's a doctor.
He's like a professor and shit.
It's Vladimir Klitschko
is like a brilliant guy,
plays chess and shit.
Dude is playing chess on his iPad.
The most boring fucking guys in
the history of the fucking sport.
The Klitschko brothers
drive me fucking crazy,
man.
Jab,
Whole Jab,
hold.
Right?
And yet fucking whole flight
mental put you to sleep.
So no to me and right.
Yeah,
me
and Elliot and uh,
I think Craig,
we're sorry,
are in Beverly Hills.
All right.
I talk so much shit about the clinch.
Go brothers hall the fucking time,
man.
All I do is fucking hammer these guys.
They're born,
it's soccer or this or that.
They're fucking,
they're,
you know,
they're one of the big problems with
boxing and fucking heavyweights.
Nobody cares as much shit as I can talk.
So there's this little
restaurant in Beverly Hills,
I'm called Elvis.
Stale,
right?
And it's literally fucking tiny,
but it's bad ass,
great food,
everything else.
So we go there for lunch one day,
walk into the fucking restaurant,
both the Klitschko
brothers and they fucking,
I'll walk into,
they both look at me.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
let's go.
Brothers are in here,
right?
So I said,
uh,
the lady says,
would you like to eat inside or out?
I said,
I'll eat outside.
Thank you.
So she'd take,
goes outside.
We tell if I like you tell Ellie and I go,
fucking,
both the Klitschko brothers are in there
and they're both fucking staring at me.
I said,
I'm probably going to get my
fucking ass whupped today.
I said,
but don't worry.
It will be boring.
They'll jab and fucking hold me for about
20 minutes over on the fucking corner
here.
And,
uh,
so then they both get up and they walk
outside and they walk by our table and
they were looking at me,
but they didn't say a word.
They didn't say anything to me,
you know?
Do you think they knew that?
I didn't know if they did or didn't,
but you know,
you know what I want somebody
talks enough shit about you.
You end up fucking hearing an event.
They were,
they were kickboxer.
Yeah,
I knew that.
So they were martial arts,
so they'd probably watched the UFC anyway.
The only makes sense that they do.
You Seen Vitaly?
There's a video of him
getting knocked out.
He got a wheel kicked.
Some guy knocked him out in some
sort of a karate tournament,
you know,
it was a,
that's the son of a bitch.
I'm a little young Joe.
Right.
That's a little young.
Me and I talked to one doe tournament and
knocked that Dude Down with a spinning
back kick.
I messed it.
Play it again.
Yeah.
That's from 1987,
the U S Cup.
This guy just sent it to me,
uh,
online.
He just found it.
He had a like a VHS tape
of it from back in the day.
Brian,
you are the worst fucking video that your,
your Internet sucks.
You don't have this already
loaded otherwise let it get it.
The Joe,
no headgear,
no nothing.
I had a headgear on.
This is the head gear is like this little
shiny black porters kick him in the
head and the chest and the
chest spinning back kick.
Yeah,
that was my technique.
That's what I worked with
George Saint Pierre on.
Yeah,
I remember.
That was my,
my specialty.
All right,
Brian,
stop.
That was my favorite technique.
It was.
So when,
uh,
George was looking for
someone to help him,
I was like,
this is gonna sound ridiculous,
but I could probably teach you
that better than anybody could.
And he actually listened to me,
which he shows you what a great guy.
He's just probably like,
yeah,
I'm going to go.
Joe Rogan wants to fucking spend time
with me or something and bullshit to me.
So I,
I was,
uh,
very impressed that he actually
came down and trained with me.
I thought this never going to believe
me because I was talking to John Danaher
and John Danaher was like,
George needs help with a
spinning back kick he's getting,
he's got the mechanics wrong.
And I was like,
this is going to sound ridiculous,
but I know the guy like,
hey,
I can help him.
But most people wouldn't listen.
You know George actually,
listen,
he's a crusty,
I couldn't say enough good
things about George Saint Pierre.
He's such,
he's such a good,
yeah,
verse man.
He's the best example of what's
possible today in mixed martial arts.
And he's a true martial artist.
Like I think that's what's interesting
about what's going on with them and may
right now is that it's
kind of coming full circle.
Like it was traditional martial arts.
In the beginning it was all about
bowing and respect and all that.
And then this became my brawlers and
sluggers and wrestlers with good haymaker
punches and now it's gone full circle.
And the greatest guys in the world are
bowing like George Saint Pierre Bowels,
Anderson Silva bows before.
I mean,
these are real fucking martial artists.
They are.
They're Real Samurai.
You know when there,
when George is living his life,
he's living his life as a true martial
artist and he's elevating the sport to
the highest level right now.
I mean,
you look at that fucking
170 pound division.
That's a murderer's row,
Hendrickson,
condit and fucking Diaz.
You got a bunch of assassins in that
division just scrambling to get at him and
every time you see him he's better.
Every time he see him,
he puts another notch in his game.
He takes time off,
it,
gets a knee surgery,
comes back bigger and stronger.
He's doing fucking gymnastics and just,
I just,
it physically,
he's a true professional man.
He gets better every time you say it.
I was just saying today,
man,
I just fucking,
you know,
the Diaz brothers,
I respect the Diaz brothers.
I like these guys.
They're fun kids.
I like the,
the,
you know,
$50,000 between the two of them now
and not showing up the film shit when,
you know you've spent $50,000 that
fucking crews running around Stockton,
you know,
it costs money to send these
fucking guys up there that,
you know,
you're paying these guys a,
these crews to do the ship by the day.
You know,
the show that we're
trying to fill now is fox,
you know,
and then you got Cesar Gracie has the
balls to get on fucking Twitter and say,
hey upgrade next ticket,
the rate Nick's going,
he's gonna be going to Montreal
and Fucking Gray Hound.
He,
he's asking you to upgrade his
ticket out or missing event.
Yeah.
It's just crazy man.
It's,
it's fucking crazy.
It's just like,
it's,
it's some,
some of the shit that goes on in this
and this fucking sports drives me nuts.
You know,
I love the Diaz brothers.
They're crazy.
I love the whole thing.
But you know,
it's like come on you guys come on.
Well who is response?
You know what else to putting
together a schedule a lot.
Cause you know,
like I read his lawyer,
yes.
Well here comes out says that wasn't true.
He's a fucking liar.
How dare you
fucking have a fucking own it
fall down and start seasoning.
I'm going to have to give
you some weed or robot.
Some of the fans were asking me,
uh,
and,
and we just did that fight
in Wembley and they were,
they thought that the dummy was there.
I was like,
you wouldn't fucking be there.
It,
he was fucking there.
It was him.
I would be,
I believe he'd be there.
Yeah,
I got it,
man.
That was that Vadim Finkelstein for
people that you call him the dummy.
People don't know what
you're talking about.
The average,
sorry.
The Dean Finkelstein is
the manager of fuel door.
Emilia [inaudible],
who was a,
at one point in time,
the,
the pride champion and,
uh,
that you guys went through a long,
lengthy debate or rather a negotiation
with them trying to bring feta or over,
but it never happened.
And then that's too bad.
That's too bad.
That guy never came over.
He just,
he's another guy that was uh,
was great during his time,
but you can only run that shit for so
long and then you can only run that game
for so long.
After a while your body just
doesn't want to do it anymore.
You don't have the motivation anymore.
He turned to religion then
and then you know for doom,
big foot Henderson,
three losses in a row like that.
It's like,
but still they would have been so fun
to have that guy come over to the UFC.
Tried man.
I know he did try hard.
But when,
when people hear about like,
like people are like,
what does he make a deal bring Fado of?
When you hear about the deal though,
it's like they were doing some crazy shit.
Like they were trying to get
cope promotion and they wanted,
I mean that's how they got m
one global on the showtime,
right?
I mean he's all like
muscling a man with a door.
Do they do fights anymore?
I don't know.
I mean like a showtime
deal after Fado has done.
Yeah,
he did have a show time.
Do you?
I don't think showtimes screwing
around with them and man,
I think they done money on Floyd.
Oh,
that's right.
They spend a lot of money
on Floyd Mayweather.
Right.
If that's a good move.
Yeah,
he's still got,
he's gonna,
they're gonna Fight Guerrero.
No,
I agree.
You know,
I think that it was a,
it was a,
it was a strong move by showtime man.
Two great moves.
Especially it's,
they don't know what the
fuck they're doing with them.
And Man,
I can get out of the business.
It's fascinating to watch
people try to get into it.
Like apparently that dude in India is
hemorrhaging cash at the Super Fight
League thing.
Worse.
Always look.
So Ken Pavio doing the
post fight interview.
He goes and does he really?
Oh my God,
that guy is such a fucking tool.
But you know,
but I think baroni me was
invicta or I think it was,
or maybe it was super tightly bro.
And he did some,
a commentary.
He's fucking hilarious.
He is funny.
His commentary is fucking like Peroni,
man.
I've always had a good relationship.
A Peroni,
one of the best commentary times I've
ever did was in Miami with Ronnie.
I mean,
let me tell you when I
say I've tried it all,
I fucking try it at all.
I really am.
Well,
that was a disaster because
I had to do goal these job,
but I don't know how to do that job.
I remember that I was freaked out like,
you know why?
Because they were talking to me like
I knew what the fuck they were saying.
Like they don't understand like
how loose doing commentary is.
Nothing can happen that I,
I,
I can't talk about something
that's not happening.
Right.
Okay.
And it has to happen
for me to talk about it.
So it's pretty fucking easy for me.
I'm,
I'll have to do is be aware
and know what's going on.
Know who the fighters are with the
strength of the weakest says ready go.
What gold he has to do.
All right.
We're gonna roll.
And he was more of a traffic
cop to open the five,
a two with a wide shot.
We'll come and do a two shot.
I go,
what the fuck are you saying?
is this written down somewhere?
You want me to read this?
And then you're like,
oh,
Jesus.
Like they thought like
maybe I'd done it before.
I was like,
no,
I've never done any of this before.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Not a described shit.
Freaking the fuck out that night.
I don't remember that.
But it worked with Barone.
It worked with Brody.
That was a,
yeah,
you really have tried everything.
I have,
man.
It's fun to be a part of this man to
be a part of it from the beginning like
that too.
It's like the old days,
you see very,
very beginning to see what it's like now.
It's a,
it's a strange shit.
I did an interview today where it's
talking about like the difference between
Dothan,
Alabama and the Roger Center.
That was probably when I,
when I was like,
really?
It was like whoa.
You know,
look around and the giant 80 foot
screen of Leo Machida jumping front,
kicking Randy in the face.
I remember just seeing
that over and over again.
This boom that that kick when Randy
would go down and I'm always like,
this is then Nadia Shit
I've ever seen in my life.
This 60,000 fucking,
it's so cool to be able to go to all these
different arenas around the world and
and meet all these different fans
from all these different countries.
Like when I was in Ireland,
the fucking people are so cool.
England,
the people are so cool.
You go to Sweden,
it's going to be fucking awesome again.
You know,
we're going back to Japan next week.
It's just like,
there's just so many fucking cool people.
That last time we went to Japan,
the fans were just insane.
It was.
It was amazing.
It's just so cool to be a part of it.
Yeah.
Brian came in Japan.
That was fun.
You know?
Are you going to Japan next?
No,
no,
I don't do,
it's a fuel fight.
Yeah.
I don't do the fuel ones or the FX.
Why?
And even while Japan,
I think about it all.
It was fun.
Yeah,
we had a good time there.
It was a fascinating little country.
And it's cool to the point where now
we're so many fans from let's say,
let's say we,
you know,
obviously went to fights in America.
People come from all over the world,
but now people from America
and all over the world,
they're going to pump fights.
And,
you know,
when we were in,
um,
uh,
only just an England,
so many,
so many
Brazilians,
they're really cool.
You know,
it's like,
how about,
how about this fucking broke
the gate record at Wembley.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Henry Cooper fought Floyd Patterson there.
Um,
Henry Cooper fought somebody else there.
I can't remember who.
Did he fight Ali there?
Uh,
no.
Um,
and then,
uh,
what's his name?
Fought there.
Uh,
Lennox Lewis fought all
of them will call there.
Lennox Lewis plot the Britain,
a European champ there.
And we beat every,
we beat every sports related
event that's ever been to Wembley.
Wow.
That cool.
Well,
MMA is huge in the UK now.
There's so many gyms coming out of the
UK and there's so many guys that are
coming out of the UK now.
He's seen like Jimmy Manawat guy.
Yeah.
That guy's a fucking beast,
man.
That was a very impressive fight.
Him and serial deal [inaudible] cause
[inaudible] days of really seasoned
striker,
multiple time World Moitai champion,
you know?
And he was excited for that fight.
It's sucked.
His leg got fucked up.
I was so excited for that.
It's tucked,
his leg got fucked up.
But I was really impressed with
Amanda what was doing before.
It's like I fucked up.
I was like,
wow,
this kid is a beast,
right?
Yeah.
He's
a,
he's a very aggressive guy.
Very a very dangerous guy.
Yeah.
It's going to be fun.
Just go,
you know,
you're right at home.
You got a guy that's got that kind of,
you know,
how,
how's his ground game going to be when
he gets up against the real good wrestler
and crown guy.
Well,
yeah,
I mean that is a,
that is always the question.
There's,
there's those guys,
you know,
like that's the big
question about John Fitch.
Like a lot of people say,
oh,
John Fitch is boring.
John fidgets,
boy.
I'm like,
Jon Finch is a reality and you
gotta be able to deal with a guy.
Like I said,
I think it's a,
it's an important aspect of
fighting that a guy made the deal,
the fight.
So exciting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That,
I mean,
John Ground that kid down
to a halt and Eric Silvers,
I was scary.
Fuck that kid.
Scary.
He's a very,
very dangerous for explosive,
real dangerous with his
knees and his striking,
he finished his fights very
quickly that Carlo prayed or fight.
I mean,
he's a dangerous kid.
The fight with um,
uh,
the Spaniard,
Charlie Brenneman,
he's a dangerous,
dangerous kid and man,
Fitch was able to glue on them.
What was crazy was watching
Damien Maia outfit Fitch,
right?
Like how good is that guy
when you see that guy?
I got ahold of Fitch and just completely
controlled and when it came to
grappling I was like,
but the big kink in his
arm wrestle standoff.
He goes,
Amiens the guy like,
yeah,
who can,
who can stop the take down?
And man at once,
heaven named me and mine is a beast.
He's a,
I mean,
he is always going to
have a problem with it.
Well,
you know,
he's gonna have a problem with it.
More cart has to be an
interesting rematch.
Everyone 70 that's a
very interesting rematch.
So matter of fact at one 70 and
a good fight from our court,
what do you got from our court now though?
Don't you have a Ellenberger yeah,
and condit versus uh,
uh,
Hendrick's Hendrick's Johny Hendricks.
Oh my God,
I love that.
It's a great card.
I it sucks it Rory Diaz versus Georgia
and tis versus George of course.
But it sucks at Rory got
hurt that that does suck.
That kid's scary.
That fight with Bj Penn was like,
man,
he,
he's one of those kids where you don't
see him for like five or six months and
then all of a sudden you're like,
Holy Shit,
this kid just got 50% better.
Like the combinations he
was throwing against Bj,
his standup look 50% better,
completely smooth robotic almost.
And it's precision.
He was throwing that question
mark kick over and over again,
throwing combinations to the body.
And then what does it,
the second round we were
really had Bj fucked up.
I was like,
this is the biggest beating
I think Bj has ever taken.
No doubt about Bj took a
beating with Nick Diaz,
but it was more of a prolonged bing,
bing,
bing that there's like a 45 second like
burst in the second round where he just
beats the shit ass.
That's why I don't want
Bj to fight any more man.
The George Saint Pierre beating the
Rory beating the nick is beating.
I mean what are those three
fights have in common?
170 fucking pounds.
Why is that guy fighting at 170 pounds?
You go back to the Bj Penn that fought
against Diego at one 55 when the
Marinovich is,
we're training them and
he was a fucking savage.
He was ripped.
He had a full six pack.
I mean Bj was super
conditioned in that fight
because the problem with Bj
Penn is he's a fucking warrior.
He's a maniac.
You don't give a fuck.
This kid went to this kid fought
Leo Machida for Christ Sakes,
heavyweight.
I'm not even at two oh five.
You know,
Bj is just incredibly talented freak who,
you know,
had,
he worked hard,
you know,
really got into it and done,
what,
what he could have done.
Who knows?
Sky's the limit for him.
But you know,
he cruised on natural ability,
heart and fucking huge balls.
And you know,
I just,
the thing is I've had my,
my beefs,
Lbj and the family,
but I really love and
respect the kid very much.
And uh,
I don't,
I just,
I don't want to see him fight anymore.
He was an amazing fighter.
But again,
I don't think,
I think fighting is such
an insane proposition that
it can only be done at the
highest levels for a few years.
You can only do it.
Somebody had a,
um,
a thing that they wrote online
about great fighters at a,
at the nine year point of their career
and that had all these great fighters
that were competing at a high
level for like nine years,
at about nine years to
start to see a waning and,
uh,
an erosion of the skills
that it's almost like,
it's almost like you got
to know when to walk away.
Age is what kills all great athletes.
You know what's going
to beat Anderson Silva?
Yeah.
H is going to beat him.
That's what's going to beat him.
Um,
especially right now,
he's just in his freaking perfect prime.
Bj Penn has nothing to prove anymore.
The guys got a bunch of money.
He's got a beautiful wife.
He's got kids.
Just fuck it,
man.
You,
you had your time and,
and you,
uh,
I just,
you know,
again,
when people talk about Joe,
I don't give a fuck about money,
man.
I really don't give a fuck about money.
I run a business and you've
got to run a business to,
you know,
to keep the thing alive and
to keep it going or whatever.
But I don't ever want to
make that kind of money,
man.
I seen Bj Penn fight again.
Well,
you don't need to make that kind of money.
And let's be honest,
he'd give a fuck about money.
You're fucking rich.
What are you talking about?
Killing time,
man.
He crazy.
When you go back to being poor again,
let me talk to you.
Oh sorry.
Let me tell you what your side,
but we tell you we'll talk
[inaudible] seen a cell phone,
John.
I honestly,
yeah,
exactly.
Actually,
I've also seen as Ferrari.
Listen,
when you got money,
there's no doubt.
You know the thing I'm telling you,
I know what you're telling me all day.
I know what you're saying.
This is fucking happy.
When I was broke,
I love what I do.
I love the sport
and I just,
I,
I'm telling you,
I really don't give a fuck.
Well,
what you don't want is that kind of
money from having a guy like Bj fight.
Don't,
haven't chucked fight and again,
or having,
well,
you can make money on those guys.
And by the way,
I'm sure chuck probably came to you
and said he wants a fight again,
I'm sure.
Yes,
no,
after we,
after we established
that pat that it was over
and he,
he,
uh,
he admitted to it and agreed
to the rich Franklin fight,
he never did it again.
Yeah.
He never asked me.
Well,
that's great.
that's smart.
That's intelligent.
You know,
there's a certain,
you mean you watched a shot that put
them away and the rich Franklin fight,
you go chocolate eat and 50 of those and,
and smiled right at.
Yeah.
In 19,
you know,
99 or 2000
vicious knock outs at
the end of his career.
The,
the Rashad Evans Scout was vicious.
Uh,
rampage knockout was vicious,
you know,
just,
yeah.
Shogun to keep doing that as just fucking
shogun rich Franklin and,
and Keith Strawn,
Jean dropped him hard to cheat,
starting hurt him.
He hit him with a big punch,
you know,
and that was,
uh,
yeah,
there's,
there's been a lot of like really crazy
fights and he'd go back to the fucking
Paly Fuck Paly bare knuckles in Brazil.
You know,
whether there's a net on the bottom of
the rank to keep guys from scooting out
and chuck stuffed Paleo a nap,
reaching over the back of the
net and punched him in the head.
There was virtually no rules back then.
Yeah,
he fought all those.
That was crazy.
I was there if they didn't
have gloves on either.
Yeah,
they didn't have gloves.
Was bare knuckle nothing.
Bare knuckle.
Yeah.
Chuck's uh,
I don't know if Chuck's
first fight in the UFC.
I think they had gloves,
but it was like when they were
just starting to use gloves.
He,
when he fought,
um,
boxer kid,
I forget the kid's name.
Ramirez.
Um,
I don't remember his name.
Martinez and Maria Martinez.
Noe Hernandez.
Hernandez.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
No,
he Hernandez.
That was when,
uh,
and I don't,
I would like to get Peretti on the podcast
when putted Peretti sent me a tweet
saying,
how come you never a want me on your show?
We had such respect for you when we,
when we hired you for the company,
but you'd never have me on your show.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
I'll have you on any day of the week.
I go,
tell me when you want to come on.
And then I never heard from him again.
All right.
I don't know why.
I don't know what happened,
but I did have that guy in a heartbeat.
He's a fascinating character,
but he told chuck that chuck had a,
he goes,
uh,
he found out the chuck was a wrestler
and I had chuck talk about it on the
podcast and he told me,
he told me when I managed chuck,
what
the Mohawks played out.
No,
nobody wants to see them a lot.
They're not bringing him back.
I said,
you're not bringing them back
because it was fucking Mohawk.
It was the craziest thing I've ever heard.
So we,
we,
we ended up,
I ended up getting him a fight.
He fought,
ah,
fuck was that guy's name.
He knocked him out.
He was the IFC champion at the time.
And,
uh,
Steve something,
remember him?
Steve IFC champion,
who's the IFC champion.
Steve something.
Chuck knocked him out and uh,
and that kind of back into the UFC.
Oh really?
Yeah.
To have a fight outside of it.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
They sat the UFC sign
chuck for two and two.
They know when to to show to the
window to MMA in New York right now.
Well,
you know,
we've got a question.
We filed this lawsuit and uh,
we had a really good response.
Basically the um,
the uh,
district attorney,
whatever,
could not
tell the judge what the language was and
why it was illegal and all this other
shit.
So basically the judge said,
you know,
we agree this is right.
They could come in here and just
be sanctioned by a federation,
like the PKA or the,
you know what I mean?
Some federation and,
and put on an event,
you guys better figure this thing out.
So it was a really,
really big win for us.
That's great.
Steve Heath,
what did I say?
I don't remember.
I say Steve something.
Yeah,
maybe he killed him in the head.
Yep.
Steve Hayes knocked him out and that's
what got chucked back in the UFC.
That fight is a Mohawk and all his fight
with knowing Hernandez was May 15th,
1998.
I was there.
That was in mobile,
Alabama.
It was a,
that was interesting time span.
That was fun.
It's been a,
it's been a fun ride.
Yeah.
So will you managing them in
the know or Hernandez days?
Um,
once,
I know wha how,
how much before that
Steve Heath fight was?
It looks like about a year.
Yeah.
So Steve Heath,
right?
Right before he bit more than a year.
Is that the fight?
It's actually almost two years.
Was there a fight in between there?
Yes.
There's a couple of fights in between.
What are the other two flights in between?
He's,
he actually fought Palae.
Yeah.
Um,
after that he fought noe Hernandez
was his first fight apparently.
Um,
and that was in the UFC and then he
went and he fought Palae over in the,
uh,
IVC in,
in Brazil,
which is the fucking
complete valley Tudo rules.
Then he fought Jeremy Horn and he got
arm triangle right after Jeremy Horn.
I started managing them.
Yeah.
And that's when he left.
What year was that?
That was in 99.
March 5th 99.
Uh,
Jeremy Horn triangled them.
Joe,
Joe Silva just texted me and said,
king mode.
Got It.
Knocked the fuck out.
Oh,
whoa.
By who?
I don't know who the king mo fight to him.
King.
Well,
what did King King Mo got released for?
Did he do something crazy?
Like what happened?
Well,
what happened was going to strike fine.
So what happened was he had a,
he tested positive for something.
Uh,
yeah,
he had some kind of steroids
or something and then,
uh,
he was on,
he was on suspension.
So while he was on suspension,
he got the offer
and uh,
I let them go.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's a,
he just,
yeah,
he just got knocked out.
Yeah.
Damn.
Is the UFC UFC ever,
uh,
id like,
thought of like a,
a different design for the octagon
or played with different ideas?
Like,
like more of like a,
like a bowl type thing or a backwards
bubble or was there any other revisions to
the auction?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
Actually when we first,
uh,
when we first started doing it,
um,
people were all freaked
out about the fence.
Even when we bought it,
I freaked out by the fence and said,
it's terrible for television.
It's just that,
could you guys put plexiglass there?
Could you started going with a cop out?
Some clear fencing so it's not,
it's clear and you
could see through it.
Um,
is that possible?
All kinds of stuff.
Have your friend,
we cleared all kinds of stuff.
You still couldn't see through
the clear stuff when it,
if it was there,
did you ever see the
thing called shoot box?
Did you ever see that?
Yeah.
Where frank shamrock did some crazy
thing where they fought in like a play.
It was like a plate,
like a giant Lego.
Yeah.
And not quite like a bowl because
it wasn't that let they let extreme,
but yeah,
sort of.
It was I think,
yeah,
I think I remember that.
That was,
and then um,
Bob Meyrowitz tried to bring you back.
Was it called Ya'll?
Yama Yama pit fire fighting,
is that what it was called?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
With some new name for it.
Yeah.
And it was like,
it was a cage though still,
but it was a cage with like a
slope to it for some reason.
Right?
Wasn't it?
No,
I remember,
I think it was like a pit
that was in the ground.
I think it was actually in the ground.
So there was no cage at all?
I don't think so.
Oh fuck.
I can't remember man.
There's been so much shit.
And then chuck to Chuck Norris,
he had that,
uh,
those kickboxing matches.
This was called like a bowl
that actually got on TV.
Yeah.
What was it called?
World Combat League.
Yeah.
I actually watched some
of those fights in Vegas.
I went and I met Chuck Norris.
Chuck Norris gave me a hug.
He knew who I was.
It was a greatest moment of my life.
Yeah.
That's cool man.
I like Chuck Norris Duck.
Yeah,
man.
Chuck Norris.
Norris is a legend.
He's a stud.
I love it.
I only have a few things in the DVR here,
but one of them is Walker,
Texas ranger.
Yeah.
They got best pride and UFC fights.
I got a bunch of UFC
fights and I've got Walker,
Texas ranger.
I love Walker,
Texas Ranger.
You remember the uh,
wait,
what was the other one?
The other one was lone wolf McQuaid.
He based the TV show off of that was
quite a bit better movie than the
television show.
It was really good.
The movie was really good.
You know,
you remember the movie,
it's hard to find these days.
The octagon.
Yes.
Where he goes and fights the Ninjas.
That's right.
Yeah.
I love that fucking,
and that was one of my
favorite movies growing up.
Yeah,
that's right.
That was the original,
I mean the octagon that's way pre UFC
where they trying to find that on DVD on,
it's almost impossible.
That term octagon is so
synonymous now with the UFC.
He never even thought that it had
another martial arts application.
Way,
way,
way back in the day.
Like when you think about an octagon,
an eight sided circle like that,
that is the UFC.
Now as you think about the octagon,
like that's the only time
I ever hear of an octagon.
I don't ever,
there's no other octagon.
I don't see them,
you know,
obviously I'm not a GM attrition.
What did,
what does it?
Geometry to college.
That's just not the same thing.
Yeah.
I mean octagon is now UFC
and that's what it is.
And you guys own that,
right?
Do you look to lease that out to people?
Yup.
So there's companies that
actually build them and stuff.
They,
they pay us a trademark fee.
Now when you guys bought pride,
did you think about keeping the key,
the,
the ring or when you were thinking about
actually trying to do shows over in
Japan as pride?
Yeah.
We were to keep the ring
and do the whole deal.
Yeah,
we were going to try to do it.
That is the craziest story of all time.
You guys paid $65 million
for essentially a video library.
So crafty.
Every deal I ever did,
everything that ever happened over there,
it was fucking crazy,
man.
They have a different way.
It's a different world over there.
When I met you,
you were this fucking regular dude
with like a job that you were like,
oh,
I don't know what I'm doing now.
To go from that to driving Ferrari's and
private jets and you've managed to be
the same guy.
How have you,
how have you not like lost your shit?
How have you not like,
I mean,
obviously you yell at people on Twitter
and say a few questionable things,
but that I,
you know,
I see,
I see so many of this.
So much of this stuff.
Go on.
Hey Elliot,
get off the phone or shut the door.
Stupid came here,
dude,
my monkeys.
I bring these fucking guys everywhere.
They fuck something up.
You have no idea.
It doesn't even realize we're doing
a fucking podcast works for you too.
Yeah,
you don't care.
It's that of a bitch.
He makes your video blogs talking.
Oh yeah,
it's a hard worker.
Oh yes,
no doubt.
He still needs to shut the
fuck up and podcasts going on.
Have you,
have you ever stepped back and go,
how the fuck did this happen?
I mean,
there's not a whole lot of people that
have that kind of a rags to riches story.
I mean,
that's a pretty fucking crazy story.
You go from 2001 to be in the president
of this unlikely president of this
company.
You Go,
you were,
you were like a,
a manager of fighters.
You know,
you had some foothold in the fight game,
you'd,
you,
he'd done boxercise class.
The only point in time where I had a
real job I've ever fucking had was,
uh,
you know,
I was a bellman when I
was 19 years old at a,
at a hotel in Boston.
And you know,
I did some construction work.
All the shit you doing here,
you know,
17,
18,
19.
And uh,
that was it.
One day I walked out of that hotel
when I was 19 years old and said,
I'm gonna be in the
fucking fight business.
That's it.
I'm done.
I'm done with this shit.
I hate coming here every day.
You know,
every other fucking week.
There was some kid that just graduated
college and would come in and start
telling you what the fuck can do.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm so done with this
shit fight business too.
But thinking about getting into
the fight business at 19 Shelly,
where the fuck even cause you
know how many fucking anymore,
but how many decisions I've
made my life to people.
Like that's the fucking
dumbest thing I've ever heard.
Like literally almost every decision
I've ever made because you have amateur
fights.
I fought in the amateurs and dude,
there was a time when I thought,
you know,
and I think that's why I can,
deal with the fighters and I understand,
you know,
like dealing with the ultimate fighter.
There was a fucking time
in a day when there was,
the only fucking thing I
cared about was boxing.
That's why I literally walked out of that
place because I loved it so much that
that's all I fucking wanted to do.
The problem is you go out
there and you start fucking,
you know that that's what I
wanted to do for a living.
And then the reality starts to set in,
and I'll never forget,
I mean I've told this before,
but
I was in the gym one day and
there was this dude who
was a local fighter.
I don't say his name.
You would probably fucking
know them if I said his name.
I guarantee,
you know,
because he was famous in the Boston area,
like a local guy.
And he came in one day and he was like,
he was in his early thirties,
he was like 31 or 32.
And uh,
he was fucked up.
You know,
he was punchy.
He fucking moping around,
kind of thrown fucked.
And I remember the day
that I looked at him,
I said,
fuck,
what if that happens to me?
And then the minute you fucking
start thinking like that,
you're,
you're not the real deal.
You're not,
no matter how much you think
you want it or you think you do.
It was the day I realized that I wasn't,
and I was fucking like,
wow.
So then you start going,
how the fuck am I going to
make a living doing this?
And me and this dude,
Peter Welsh from Boston started,
uh,
you know,
teaching people how to box
basically businessman and stuff.
Cause the,
the,
the business model wasn't first.
It's like martial arts.
If you want to take a martial arts class,
it's fucking 50 martial arts
studios anywhere in any city,
anywhere in the world.
And it has been since I was a kid.
Right.
And he
lack of martial arts schools around
your place when you were growing up.
No.
So if you want to buy,
but if you want a box,
you got to go and fight.
You got to go get your
fucking head punched in.
You know what I mean?
You know,
especially,
you know the places in Boston,
you had the Somerville Boxing Club had
the fucking place down at the mcdonough
down in South Boston.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the,
the Petronellis down in Brockton and,
and places like that.
And you went in and they would fucking,
you'd get your dick knocked loose.
Right.
And if you came back,
maybe they'd fucking work with you.
Well,
even guys had lights.
You would do that.
Like I got,
I got trained by Joe Lake and that's,
that's what he did with me.
He just stuck me in with guys.
You know that a box and they all do.
They all do.
They do it quickly too.
Like we're right right from the beginning.
Find out how much you enjoy doing this.
Do you really want to do it?
Then they're wasting my time here.
Exactly right.
I'm going to teach you how to throw
some punches and then we're going to put
your head gear on.
Let me put your fuck of Vaseline on your
face and then they can show me what you
got.
The first time they ever went into box,
they had me do fucking rings circles.
You know what?
Those are right where you go laterally
around the ring fucking coming in every
day they have to ring circles,
rink circles,
rank circles,
and I was like,
what the fuck?
I paid my dues.
I paid my fucking eight bucks.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
I fuck you got mad one day I said,
I came here and learn how to fucking box.
Man.
I've been running around in circles
for fucking weeks and he's like,
Oh,
you want to learn how to box,
right fucking fucking gear you up,
man.
Love.
Yet they throw you in there.
They
beat the fuck Outta you.
Fucking dropped me 50
times with body shots,
punching my fucking head.
In the worst of the body
shots when you first started,
you start taking some body shots from a,
who knows how to throw him and uh,
you know you're fucking lips are bleeding.
Your nose is bleeding.
You're fucked up.
You get out.
You're completely morally destroyed.
You know what I mean?
Because boxing is never,
or sparring is never what
guys think it's going to be.
You know,
your watch too many fucking movies.
You go in there and you think you're
going to spar and you get shit kicked out
of you.
But then,
you know,
I went home that night and I remember
laying in bed thinking the whole might
fuck I got my ass whooped that slug,
this,
that,
and I went back to the gym
the next day and that was it.
There no working with you
blacks.
They want to fight.
They just want to kick someone's ass.
It's true.
They don't understand that.
That kind of kick your ass too.
Like this is not going
to be an even exchange.
And if you're not willing to go to war,
if you're not willing to take like big
shots and be in pain and push through,
you're never going to do this.
This is you.
You,
you have to figure out somewhere along
the line whether or not you're willing to
take punishment,
whether an old picture
punishment,
some guys can't.
So that was what our,
what our business was based on.
You know,
Peter,
I,
yeah you could come,
you could come into the real gym.
We're real fighters trained and you learn
how to box just like white collar box.
Yeah.
So it was like you learn how to box but
you didn't get your ass kicked every
day.
But some guys,
you know,
start trained for so long and get to
the level where they want to start
sparring.
But you rarely ever have white collar
guys that start sparring and want to do at
a fucking again.
Cause you know,
like I said,
you get that first ass weapon and a,
and a lot of times what
happens is it breaks,
breaks out into fights,
you know.
And uh,
we,
we had,
we used to,
we used to bring the
inner city kids in too.
You know,
we had this idea where we're going to
bring in an inner city kids and you know,
in southeast back then it
was still very segregated.
So we are going to bring in blacks and
Hispanics and all these other kids and
bring them together and you know,
we're going to do all the fuck.
We used to bring these kids in man.
And we started training them and stuff.
And then as soon as guys
would start sparring,
you know,
how many fucking situations we had were
guys would come back and with bats,
like there'd be a bad sparring deal,
come back with bats or they'd come back
with their brothers or some kind of crap
just every fucking day.
That was so that whole,
you know,
let's bring in the inner city
kids and fucking tried to work.
It didn't go over well.
Yeah.
That's playing that
experiment and then work to
a lot of work.
It's interesting to see the uh,
the attitude,
you know,
that used to exist back then,
the boxing gyms and now that people are,
we're,
we're seeing this evolution in mixed
martial arts where the beginning,
we saw a lot of like gym wars,
like that would be like a really normal
occurrence in gyms where guys would just
beat the fuck out of each other.
And you hear about fighters getting
knocked out in the gym left and right and
left and right.
But now I think people are
starting to realize like,
Whoa,
whoa,
hey,
there's no fucking benefit in this.
Like what's going on here?
But we're gonna we're
looking at a gigantic multi,
multi,
multimillion dollar business and this is
how we're treating our commodities and
our prospects.
We're,
we're throwing at each
other and lend them,
blast each other and due to getting
punchy way before their time.
And we both know Jim's work guys,
they get Chiney way too quick and you go,
well,
what?
How's this guy like this guy had
an iron changes three years ago.
Well,
let's take a fucking gym wars.
He's going through gym
wars on a regular basis.
That was shoot the box.
That was the deal at shoot the
box and shogun himself said like,
we realize,
you know,
after doing that for awhile,
we can't do that anymore.
What?
I know
I,
that's how it was in boxing too though.
When I,
when I was involved in boxing,
some of the best fights I
ever saw her in the jet.
Oh yeah.
Oh hell yeah.
One day,
one day I saw uh,
uh,
Livingstone bramble and Roger Mayweather.
Oh fucking go at it.
At a fucking gym in Vegas.
Yeah.
Another time.
Wow.
One of the gyms cause cause
we all worked together.
I worked with Mayweather,
I worked with Nick one kick,
um,
Floyd when Floyd was first coming.
I mean we all worked
together in these gyms,
you know.
And uh,
one time there was this dude,
he was the heavyweight,
his name is Tracy and him and Roger
Mayweather fucking got into it.
He was,
Tracy was a young heavyweight,
24 year old kid,
heavyweight.
And Roger was fucking one 47.
Yeah.
In his forties.
And Roger said,
what you say mother,
is it done at the fucking gate into it?
Both the back and forth.
I go,
Oh shit.
Here we go.
And they got in the fucking
ring and start a fight,
man.
Yeah.
They started fucking fighting.
And at the end of the round
when the bell went off,
Tracy tried to stop and Roger
fucking lit him up and he goes,
no rounds,
motherfucker,
no routes.
So they just kept fighting straight
fucking through until fucking Tracy quit.
Oh my God,
you're fucking whooped his ass.
And he fucking quit.
And forties.
Yeah.
And then,
and then when he quit,
Roger hit him another eight,
nine times after you fucking quit.
And He,
and he was basically like,
don't ever fucking mouth off to me.
And this gym,
uh,
one 47 pound 40 year olds,
but Roger May Mamba.
Yup.
You know,
a lot of people don't know Roger.
You know a lot of people,
everybody knows Floyd.
But Roger,
his uncle in his time,
he was a bad motherfucker.
He had a piston right hand.
Yep.
He had a nasty jab and he would
fucking slam that right hand in.
He was a bad dude for many a year.
I've seen some crazy shit happened
in fucking jet boxing gyms,
man.
Crazy shit over the years.
That's incredible.
That's,
would you ever hear
about the Floyd Mayweather thing where
like when he was dealing with those wrap
guys and they came in and beat guns,
people and Shit?
Yeah.
What was that all about
you again at one point?
You Fuck?
Yeah,
I remembered I wasn't there so I can't,
you know,
this isn't like right fucking
eye witness testimony,
but I,
I heard about it too and what I heard
was the dude that was managing him at the
time was like a hardcore,
like real dude and a,
and he didn't just walk into a gym.
I already walked into top rank their
gym pistol whipping people and fucking
pulling out guns with Floyd
and shit and kind of sets
just whatever their beef was.
Got It straightened out.
Yeah.
Box.
That's boxing man.
Racy fucking business.
That's boxing.
Here's the knockout right here.
Boxing is a crazy,
this is king mo.
Oh Shit.
He got spinning back fist.
Do you wish you had a look at,
wow.
Do you wish you had a
10 minute first round?
Oh,
look at that.
Perfect.
Spinning back fist.
Well,
you know what he's been playing with.
Uh,
he's been doing a lot of boxing.
You know,
he's been training at Floyd's place.
He's been working with,
uh,
the Mayweathers.
That's,
that's great.
But you got to look out for
that spinning back fist to man,
you gotta look out for these
crazy fucking techniques.
Okay,
let me sleeping.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well that's a devastating technique.
There's so much torque into that.
That dude's Reddit rear naked choke on.
It was already out.
He's a bad ass where I
started to Kang Mile,
I thought that he was going to
have a very bright career in Mla.
I remember Brian,
well,
I still can.
Brian Parsons is a Ryan Parsons Rather.
Ryan Parsons is very high on that guy.
Just like unbelievable athlete.
He said he'd never seen anybody just
throw around like real experience,
restless the way King Mo could.
Yeah.
When that whole thing went down with him
and we've sat down and talked one day
we'd never met and a smart guy though.
Great Guy.
I like him a lot.
When you have a conversation with him,
he's actually a really smart guy.
Can ever have your hands down,
can ever have your hands down like that.
You mean being cocky and being,
having a swagger and everything is great.
But man,
when a guy clip she on the channel and
I'll see it common to fucking the light.
Shut off stuff.
Not a lot you can do about
the human body's design.
Yup.
I agree.
It's amazing how some guys could
just take ridiculous shots though.
Some guys just take,
it's true.
I think if you're,
if you're,
it's one of those things
that you can't train.
You can't fucking do.
You either have a cin or you don't.
How about Fabio Maldonado and Glover
to sharer that crazy fucking file?
That was,
I had never seen anybody take,
oh yeah.
Ridiculous.
You know,
as long as that guy has been around,
as long as,
again,
when you talk about a guy
who's been a fucking war dog,
you know,
just 40 yeah.
40 years old and they still have it all.
Still have the punch of power,
still have the ability to,
to fight these guys at his age.
And He's also on testosterone
replacement therapy.
Right?
Yeah.
But you know,
in that there is,
there's something in that as far
as longevity and staying around,
but Oh,
you're either fucking good or you're not.
Well,
he was awesome.
He had it.
But there's a lot of guys that are on
testosterone replacement therapy that
couldn't fight a fucking lick.
That's true.
But it is a,
it's a funky subject now.
And that,
I'm not a fan.
I'm not a,
you're not a fan.
No.
Because it,
it allows a guy like
Dan Henderson to fight.
But if,
I mean,
if you've got a guy like Dan Henderson
is taking it responsibly and not,
not going over his limits
and the exact amount of,
that's what was going on.
Yeah.
But I,
I truly believe that
that's not what's going on.
I agree.
Well,
you know what,
here's the problem.
This is what I've said before
about replacement therapy.
You know,
say he give a guy a bottle of whiskey
and you gave it to him and he said,
hey man,
don't ever take more than one glass a day.
Okay,
here's the whole jug.
What are the guys now like a hawk.
But if he's indulgent,
what was he crazy guy?
Well,
a lot of people were indulging.
When you take shit like that,
you feel like a fucking superhero man.
You're like,
wait a minute.
Well not only that,
but up just a little bit more and
let's pump it up a little bit more.
And,
and you taking self indulgent ridiculous
athletes who are fighters in the first
place.
They're crazy reckless motherfuckers.
And you're saying,
hey listen,
you just kind of a little jug of this
shit laying around and a couple of needles
and hey,
if there's only half the amount of
needles that are supposed to be here,
who cares?
I'm your doctor.
Come on,
I love Ya.
Like watching a fight on TV.
I love how these guys are
doctors by name on your shorts.
He's testosterone.
Guys are fucking doctors.
Write,
write a prescription for you.
I want to write one on me now.
Well it's hilarious that weed is illegal.
That,
I mean there's some people
that think that weed,
I've argued that weed is possibly
a performance enhancement.
Um,
w with people who smoke,
a lot of it,
every dude that I've ever known the
smokes weed turns into a fucking Zombie
after he smokes weed.
How could it be a
performance enhancing drug?
I love saying that.
Love with me and you're getting into this
shit cause I say that because I don't
know cause that's two
different types of wheat.
First of all,
there's Endeca and sativa.
Endeca is the far more
common style of weed.
And what that is is like,
it's known as like,
Oh gee,
Kush is what people usually cause.
That's like what snoop
Dogg smokest amazing goes
like real like mellow couch.
We'd right.
Then there's like Carl Sagan weed,
Carl Sagan.
Weed is sativa and sativas much
more of like an upper type of weed.
It makes you want to watch documentaries,
makes you want to write.
It makes me want to go running
and makes you want to do things.
A lot of people don't
understand that I've met,
I've never heard that.
Well it's harder to grow there.
There's South American
strains and they're,
they're,
they require a different growing cycle.
They would require their,
they're usually from
where the equator and the,
you can only grow them
in doors in America.
So when you're getting these,
these,
their,
their low yield,
they don't yield as much,
they're harder to grow and you don't
get as much marijuana out of it.
So most of the stuff that you get,
it's like that sleepy
sort of narcotic wheat.
But the stuff that I get
is not like that at all.
Like that's why people say,
well you do so much shit and
you're a pothead or Sorta Yam.
Well first of all I'm not,
I take a lot of days off of smoking pot.
I don't believe in
doing anything everyday.
But the stuff that I smoke is not the
kind of stuff that makes you tired.
It's kind of stuff that
makes you think about shit.
It's kind of stuff that we're
going to give you free money.
Oh my gosh,
trait.
You're writing the fuck out of
my fucking head would explode.
I think about too much shit already.
You do Bobby lying back,
looking at these constellations going,
what the fuck am I doing?
I'm going to find business.
Do you wish,
uh,
daddy had the tooth,
you being a creep.
Do you wish there was a,
uh,
the first round tendons somewhere,
man,
sit down.
You fuck.
Stop wandering around.
Do you,
do you ever wish that,
that,
that you had to at first round,
now you're reading shit off the forms.
No.
This is something I,
we talked about like two weeks ago and
I just wondered what Dana thought about
it.
Do I ever wet wish that,
that you had a 10 minute first round?
Kind of like the old pride days.
I thought what they used to do.
No,
no,
no.
It's great for GAM.
For grapplers.
Yeah.
I liked,
I liked the structure where it is you get,
you get three,
five minute rounds or five,
five minute rounds.
Um,
do you like five,
five minute rounds for non title fight?
So yeah.
Do you feel like I do
if it's the main event,
you know,
and I think that's the real problem that
everybody had with Ronda Rousey be in
the May event is they wanted to see
Henderson but she did five rounds.
Well we were talking about,
and we didn't really finish it,
but the real issue with the testosterone
replacement therapy is that these guys
can take this shit and check
themselves up through the fucking roof.
Right.
While they're whole trailer through,
through,
throughout training and suffer.
I mean there's a,
it's really,
they're not going to get any real problems
if they're just doing it for six to
eight weeks,
they're going to be fine if they do it.
So it's not like it's a dangerous
thing to them and the benefit is pretty
substantial.
The benefit as far as performance,
you get to hyper human levels and
as long as your body sustains,
you don't cover faster flight
training session like that.
And that is a,
that's undeniable.
It's undeniable.
And when you look at some guys and you
see like the massive differences in their
physiques and that how,
how quickly,
you know,
like you look,
some of these guys you look at like,
I don't want to mention names,
let's go with Vitara for his
last fight against Bisping.
He looked fucking fantastic,
right?
I mean you want to have a poster boy
for testosterone replacement therapy.
I'd be like,
whatever the fuck that guy's on,
give it to me.
It looks fantastic.
All right.
I mean,
and the weigh ins,
well fucking shredded.
Perfect.
And the big question after that
fight was everybody's like,
is he going to pass the drug test?
Is he going to pass the drug test?
And he did.
He did.
But according to,
it's not even that he
passed the drug test.
I mean he was being monitored.
Yes.
For the fight too.
Was he being monitored like all
throughout the camp to before,
two weeks before.
See,
but as long as they know when,
I mean I'm not accusing veto of anything,
but I'm saying that if a fighter was
like if he was willing to bend the rules,
as long as he knew when he
had to come in and Piss,
it's not hard to super
elevate your levels.
That's one of the things,
I know you're not a fan of victor content,
but one of the things that he enlightened
beyond about drug testing is that the
actual benefits of the steroids
go far beyond the time we test.
Positive to tell you what I don't
like about Victor fucking Conti,
this fucking piece of shit.
He's,
he's this fucking guy.
What I don't like about him is with the
tooth is over there like a fucking CIA
spy snapping pictures to
think through this as,
yeah,
this is my life.
You have no idea.
So this fucking guy is the biggest
cheater in the history of fucking sports.
Yet.
Now after he gets busted and fucking
rolls over and his buddies and shit wants
to come out and act like he's
trying to save fucking sports,
do,
don't,
don't come out and start point,
come on my fucking Twitter and start
pointing your fucking finger at me and
saying,
oh,
the UFC isn't doing the fuck you.
Well,
the UFC does not have the
obligation to do that.
It's under the obligation of the Vata
State Athletic Commission to deregulate
and if they want to make
more stringent rules,
which they have.
I mean that's how they caught Overeem.
They decided to do some
random testing and that's how,
I mean there's a there,
there's obviously been some,
some movement May to try to regulate
certain certain aspects of a,
of MMA,
but
and our fighters are
fighters get hot fought.
The consequences are huge.
Are huge.
A year of no work.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's what I just don't think the media
and some of the fans really wrapped
their fucking brains around.
Yeah,
it's devastating.
It's devastating for your confidence.
It's devastating for your career.
You've got to answer
questions everywhere you go.
It's a huge,
huge,
huge loss.
And if it happens again,
boy,
then you're really fucked.
Then you really fucked.
And domains are substantial as well.
Don't you lose your wind bonkers?
You lose.
Yeah.
You lose your win bonus.
So imagine that happening in football.
Oh my baseball.
As much as it can happen in MMA,
if you're being regulated
by the government,
well,
the football thing is ridiculous because
there's no way you get humans that big
unless they're doing something.
I mean,
everybody knows it.
I have a friend who,
uh,
was a in competitive high
school football and uh,
he's now,
he's a a technician.
Like he say I'm an it guy,
brilliant guy.
But he told me they were giving
him steroids in high school.
All right.
He goes,
I was,
he goes,
I was a competitive football player.
And they were,
they were giving me steroids.
I was like,
how old were you?
He was like,
I was 17.
I was like,
that's fucking crazy.
Who else in your team was on steroids?
He goes,
we were all on steroids.
I go,
what the fuck are you saying your
coach was giving you steroids?
He goes,
yeah,
he goes,
we were in a serious,
like it was a very
competitive team and the,
they let us know what we needed to do
if we wanted to get bigger and stronger
and we're all like,
what?
Like you get you got it.
And so like when you're 16,
17 your coach says,
do you want steroids?
Um,
yeah,
coach,
I want to win
Vegas during high school.
And when I was in high school,
it was a doctor in town.
You went and got in his
weight grading program,
weight gain program,
they call it.
And what did they do?
They would,
they would give you injections and pills.
You told both shots and
pills in high school.
That crazy
shit.
I had a kid that I went to
high school with and went,
that was on roids.
He was,
um,
I don't want to say his name.
Very nice guy turned I.
Years later I saw him and he says,
shit shriveled up.
He weighs like 160 pounds now.
But when we were in high school,
everybody was terrified at this kid.
He was like
250 pounds.
Five foot seven.
Okay.
Who was fucking maybe five,
eight Jai Gantt tick.
I mean just shooed stretch
marks all over his chest.
His arms were enormous.
I don't know what he was taken,
but he was on some super
hyper elevated levels.
He was playing football and this guy
just juiced it to the gills and everybody
kind of knew.
But it was not a like fucking
the eighties man ever.
No one else there.
Right.
But this was,
I was in high school.
We didn't know anybody
else that was doing it.
How old are you?
I am 45 45 so I graduated
in [inaudible] 85 87.
This guy was,
he was a year older than me and um,
he was on the football team and
everybody knew that he was on steroids,
but no one else knew anybody else.
It wasn't like there was like a
whole epidemic of people on steroids,
but there was this one guy that was
just unbelievably ridiculously big and
aggressive and he like,
he kept it
up for like a few years and then just got
off the shit and just shriveled up til
like nothing.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck happened?
And he didn't really talk about it.
And it was,
it was very strange.
But for a short period of time,
this 17 year old kid was 200 fucking and
whatever pounds of just shredded muscle
coming out of his head.
I mean it was incredible what they
were willing to do to this kid
that was like that in Vegas.
Every,
every single school in Vegas
was competitive with football.
Man.
They say it's a real issue with
high school kids these days,
cause they know about it.
Especially football players,
man,
kids who played football,
you know,
it just being bigger as being better.
Yeah.
That's a,
and there's a real lottery in that.
I mean,
if you're a an impoverished kid
in a bad community and you can,
you know,
if you're big,
you're six foot four and
you could fucking run man,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
football's you.
Your big ticket.
Sure is.
Yeah.
For every football,
go to a good high school,
you go to a good college,
you go to good college,
maybe can go to the NFL or at least
get an education and it's just,
there's so much at stake.
One of the
craziest things I've ever heard about
football is that 80% of the NFL players
are bankrupt within two years of retiring.
80% and 60% of NBA players,
80% and you deal with the,
the impacts of head impacts and football.
Like there's,
there's certainly head impacts in MMA,
but the head impacts and football are
dudes running at each other running full
clip,
300 pound men slamming into each other,
run as fast as track stars.
Oh yeah.
Spiking each other in the fucking head.
He'll go and helmet to helmet.
Yeah,
lightened each other up.
My son plays football.
My son's a quarter,
my both my sons do.
Once a quarter back.
The other one plays defense.
Yeah.
People always ask me,
I'm like,
I'd rather have my kids fight.
Fight.
Yeah I would.
And they do.
They fight too,
but I'd rather fight then.
Then,
uh,
then play football.
What did,
what,
what are you going to do?
My,
my oldest son is a lunatic.
It's all he cares about his football.
It's all he wants to do.
It's all he cares about.
Has he had anything?
Can get that from me.
You know,
it,
it's just what he loves.
Has he had any cash?
Not that I'm aware of.
No.
Yeah.
Do you know that there's been,
um,
I know you love,
you're gambling.
You're a crazy gamble.
Fuck right.
Do you know that there's a
direct correlation between
gambling and brain damage?
Yeah.
Well,
that's funny you say that.
Do you ever thought about that?
Yeah.
No.
W W you know,
it was funny.
It was when I went to,
uh,
you know,
when that whole Tito thing was happening,
I had to go in and get full medicals done.
So,
you know,
from I,
I the only times I've
been punched in the head,
you know,
probably a lot,
a lot and not,
you know,
I went in and I did have,
I had spots on my brain.
Yeah.
So when uh,
what does that mean?
It's just,
you know,
it's trauma that's damage that's
been done to you from being punched,
you know,
and whether you play football,
you've,
you know,
you boxed or you did mixed
martial arts or whatever it is.
Any type of blows
to the head.
Prolonged blows to the head for years.
So I was getting punched in the head
till I was 31 years old then I didn't do
any anything for maybe
three or four years.
And then I'll tell you what man,
getting ready for that.
Tito fight fucked me up bad man.
I really
well you were sparring.
I really hurt myself.
A lot of people don't even
know what that was like.
You had made some sort
of a deal with Tito.
If you resigned them,
you would like box him.
Peto put in the contract that if he
came back and we did this new deal,
part of the deal was that me and
him had to fight in a boxing match.
Three three minute rounds.
So you agreed to it and
then you started training.
I remember you were,
you were still managing the UFC,
right?
And you are bringing guys out with you
and you were telling me about these
fucking wars that you would get any
sparring sessions with these animals like
the wheel.
Yeah,
I brought in heavyweights.
I brought him real heavyweights guys,
boxers,
real heavyweight kit kids that were,
you know,
there was one kid that,
huh?
How was 37 I was 37 when I did this.
Dude,
I'm telling you right now,
I'd be sitting on my fucking office,
right?
And I kept,
she remember that's the movie three
o'clock I with the kids going to kick the
dude's ass after school.
He's trying to get out of
fucking getting his ass kicked.
I'd be looking at the clock.
I go,
oh my God,
fuck,
I'm on the clock.
Those dudes are going to be here in two
hours because I would spar three o'clock
and I sparred every fucking day.
I'm in the middle of,
at once.
I got in shape and uh,
I was sparring with these heavy real,
we brought,
we brought in professional boxers that
it was foreign with and I'm telling you,
man,
I fucking then the day
for me to get my license,
the commission had to see me box.
So they want to know who I
was boxing with that day.
So I brought in this kid,
uh,
this heavyweight,
I'm going to have to ask
Kipper Kelp what his name was,
but he's still fighting today.
He just fought for,
I think he,
uh,
he was,
I think he's ranked number
six in the world right now.
And this kid came in and that the kid
I sparred with that day and we had a
fucking war because the commission was
watching and I wanted to make sure these
guys gave me an license and this
dude wasn't taking it easy on.
This guy was fucking putting it to me.
I was like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
Is he trying to kill me right now?
Is He's trying to make
me knock at the license.
So I said fuck it.
We got to go all out of here are these
guys aren't gonna fucking license.
So he was trying to show off.
They didn't come,
they didn't want to license me anyway.
I mean this whole thing,
I really kind of got a bad relationship
with some of the commissioners through
me getting this license to fight Tito.
It wasn't a good thing.
So we had a fucking war that day.
Me and this guy,
I mean fucking dropping
bombs on each other,
right?
So when it was over,
my nose was so fucked up after getting
ready for that Tito fight that I had to
go have surgery and I snore like a beast.
And I don't know if you can
tell when you look at me,
I got like red lines seems like the
red lines and outside of my nose.
I don't know why the fuck that there,
but it didn't use to be there
and now I snore like crazy.
I already had a surgery.
The surgery didn't,
that didn't work.
It was like,
but man,
that Tito thing
you will use.
That was my last Hurrah.
You had deviated septum
surgery and it didn't work.
Didn't work,
man.
Mine were great.
I had a great doctor
and glad to hear that.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Mine sucked.
Actually knows wider though.
It's funny.
I like looking at photos.
Makes Sense.
Something they like,
why didn't my know something
that's so much better,
man.
I go back to how it used
to be most of my life.
I couldn't breathe out of my nose.
Yeah.
I broke my nose when I was five.
I fell down a flight of stairs and
from then a lifetime of martial arts,
boxing and wrestling.
It was just mashed.
It was just the inside was all fucked
up and yours is still like that.
I'd go in again,
man.
I'd get a better doctor.
I'm done with surgery is fuck that shit.
He'll snore.
Fuck it.
I'm going to get the
mouthpiece like you told me.
I keep saying I'm going to do it.
I just need that.
Yeah,
you don't.
You have a sleep apnea too?
Yeah,
I got it bad.
I don't sleep at all bro.
I don't sleep at all.
You need to sleep.
He can die.
Shit ain't good for your heart,
son.
I know.
What are you doing?
I'm on.
We're all getting money now.
You've got resources.
We're all going to die.
Yeah.
We don't have to die this way.
Drinking some green shit over there.
You must be at least
thinking about your health.
You,
you've basically worrying about your diet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got it.
I'm on this diet because of the ear.
What does it do?
What does the uh,
I stay away from salt and all kinds of,
there's all kinds of
shit that triggers all.
Sounds good for you?
Not For me.
It's bad for me.
Yeah,
it's probably sodium and salt.
Um,
but actual natural caffeine,
caffeine,
all that shit triggers this alcohol.
All the fun shit.
Really?
Yeah.
All the fun stuff.
I was cake cake fucked up.
I haven't,
I haven't eaten.
I've seriously for like,
I've lost 18 pounds in
the last four weeks.
What would make sense that keeping
your body healthy would stop them.
The nearest town.
Plus I'm just doing everything I can to
try to kick this thing and get healthy
again.
Did the boxing accentuate it?
Did it make it worse when you sit here?
Any for the Tito fight?
Oh No,
I didn't have it then.
I had,
I had it.
It was for me,
but I didn't actually have them.
I didn't get them in years.
My first attack was,
uh,
not this past Christmas,
but the Christmas before.
Well,
what do you think brought it on?
It's just time and you know,
all this stuff that
happened in Boston and yeah,
the accumulation of punches over the last,
you know,
however many years.
But yeah,
I,
I have spots on my brain when I
went in for that thing and you know,
there's,
when you do this for a living,
you know,
it's like,
it's not like,
you don't know that there's risks.
I always knew there were risks the
whole time that I was doing it,
but it was what I love to do.
You know,
if I could go back and do it all again,
I wouldn't change one thing.
Wow.
I might have turned down the Tito fight,
but just,
yeah,
the brain damage seen and cry.
Again.
Chronic gamblers,
it's a,
there's been a lot of studies on
that lately that they don't know why,
but they,
there's a direct correlation.
People who have suffered
brain damage and loving the game,
I can tell you that.
So it was a gamble or before
I ever had brain damage.
Oh yeah.
I've always loved gambling
since I was a kid.
I grew up in Vegas Bro.
I used to,
I used to go to the casinos and literally
you could fucking hang out cause he
knows when.
Back in the old days,
you know,
you didn't get chased out
like you do that today,
you know,
there's so many more rules and regulations
in Vegas than there used to be when I
was growing up there.
You're talking early eighties
like 1980 81 stuff like that.
So you will show boat,
the Shoba Boston.
By then we moved.
My family lived in Boston.
We moved to Vegas when
I was in third grade,
so I consider myself really from Vegas
because that's where I really grew up.
And you went back to Boston?
Went Back to Boston when I
was 17 I moved back there.
What happened?
I didn't really move back there.
I went back there on vacation
and I just fucking stay.
That was having a blast back there.
I said,
fuck it.
I'm going to stay.
So I just stayed.
Wow.
Fuck standing.
But I used to,
I used to go into the casinos
and watch guys played big money.
Just watch guys played big money
and watches these guys going,
Holy Shit.
What's the most money you've ever gamble?
50 grand.
What's the most money you've ever gambled
the most I've ever lost in one night.
$8 tellers.
Okay.
What's the most you've ever lost someone?
1 million bucks.
Oh.
Oh my God.
How'd you sleep?
Pretty good.
Elliot.
Elliot's been with me for some praise.
The ones.
How much is it?
What's the most you've ever won?
6 million.
Oh Jesus,
one 6,000,090 6 million bucks.
Oh my God.
He said treated.
The reason why we don't go back to the
palms is because they cut back your a
your gambling budget because
you were killing him.
Yeah.
Really?
That seems ridiculous,
but that's the way Vegas is now,
but that seems ridiculous that
they would do that with you,
but that's the way Vegas is now.
These guys,
these guys,
the way the economy is and stuff,
Vegas ain't what it used to be,
brother.
You look at the wind,
go try to play big money at the
wind that the other pussies.
It's fucking
great.
Did you see what happened in Vegas today?
There is.
There was a shootout right on the strip
and a rapper's dead and like three
people are dead.
Who's the rapper?
His name is Kenny Chery
junior or a rapper.
Also known as kidney clutch.
Have you heard of him?
No.
Me Neither.
But yeah,
there's all the where where,
where,
where did it happen?
I believe it was right
in front of the Bellagio.
Whoa.
Oh,
big shootout happened and people
just started getting shot.
Yeah.
How many people got shot and start around
4:20 AM a dispute in the valet lot of
the area,
hotel,
Aria Hotel and about a block
away and then the driver was hit.
The Maserati continued into
the intersection of the
boulevard and Flamingo Road
and collided with a taxi which
caught fire and like a movie,
three other people died in it.
Okay.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
That is freaky.
Do you remember when the all star,
the NBA star game came to Vegas?
This fucking crazy.
Murders and shootouts there?
I'm telling you,
I was actually funny cause it was the
Bellagio when that thing was there.
I was at the Bellagio and it was just,
it was bad man.
It was like,
it's just just a bad five in there.
And it was weird.
It was the week.
I don't know.
It's just,
I'll tell you what,
it felt like.
It felt like the night that I was at
the Tyson and Holyfield fight when he
fucking bit his ear and all that shit.
The Night Tupac got shot.
Dude,
I was fucking there that
night and it was bad.
I mean,
they didn't report how bad it really was.
People were fucking grabbing
chips off the table.
People were jumping on top of the,
on top of the tables.
I remember when we
walked out of the fight,
somebody took and through the programs,
slap them out of the guy's hands and
people were just going fucking crazy.
It's weird.
And people who are listening might
have been in this situation before,
especially Canadians and
shit cause it fucking hockey.
But when the riot starts to break out,
it is a creepy,
weird feeling man.
But I can't explain it.
And people who have been in it will
understand what I'm talking about.
You feel it starting to happen.
And I was like,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here man.
Um,
and we,
uh,
we got out and we started
to felt like a bad,
it was felt like a wave was
coming behind us and just shit,
what's going on everywhere.
And then we got out just in time
before they locked that place down.
Yeah.
They don't fuck around in Vegas,
man.
I remember when we were in Vancouver and
then there was the riots right after we
left the hockey.
Right.
That was right after we left.
Yeah,
it was fucking crazy.
Right.
Cause that was the first time there was
like real accountability for that shit
where they got photos
of everybody doing it.
Like,
Hey asshole,
we know who you are.
And I,
and after all these guys and
they were like regular college.
Yeah.
These days with all the cameras.
The other thing last,
uh,
you know,
I like going to to Celtic Laker games,
man and la La.
It's awesome.
That's the best.
I love doing it.
So for game seven,
um,
last time that the Lakers played
the Celtics in the championship,
I was there for game seven
Celtics of winning the whole game.
They ended up losing at the end,
right.
So we leave and we're leaving and we're
starting to drive way they fucking one.
All right.
People are jumping on cars.
People started,
you know,
you're,
you're in traffic getting out of there
and people are just jumping on your
fucking car and jumping from car to car.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is crazy.
So we go over this restaurant
that's down the street,
the palm,
and we're going to go over there and eat
and I get out of the car and all these
people out there,
all these Laker fans.
I'm like,
Dana,
why?
What's up Dana White?
You're a fucking Celtics Fan,
aren't you?
I said,
Huh,
I don't even fuck a watch.
Basketball
wasn't even there for the game.
Fucking get to know Wyatt
with the fucking Laker fans.
Are you kidding me?
They get me the fuck outta here.
Didn't they?
The Dodgers beat the shit out of some
fucking kid giants fan and killed him or
no crippled him.
He's really,
really,
really fucked up.
Yeah,
that's a thing that fucking,
that thing that happens after games in La,
it happens a lot.
They liked cars on fire
and flip him over and shit.
Even if they win,
it's like they are looking
for an opportunity to do
something really crazy and
fucked up.
I almost died at the last UFC because
you tweeted a tickets at Mandalay bay and
there was just this roar coming down the
hallway and I turned around and there
was probably a good 200 people running
down the hallway of Mandalay bay.
Yeah,
we've had some bad situations
with tweeting tickets.
I usually try to control it as best I can.
How the worst ever was in Toronto.
Toronto was really scary.
We had a bad situation up there where
people just went fucking crazy and we're
trying to rush in and I'm
looking down and I see these,
you know those girls in there
too and they're getting smashed.
It's freaky.
It's freaky
big people too.
Usually
not a big people coming my way.
Yeah.
The last time you went to fight,
the last time place you want to
start a fight is in the crowd to UFC.
So true man.
Who the fuck is in there?
And 90% of them train.
So true.
It's funny because you know,
you say that I was driving
the other day and uh,
and I,
and I had one of my buddies in the car,
right.
And I said,
you see that dude at the light
and this fucking dude with Lanky,
skinny as hell glasses on,
fucking pasty white fucked up here guy
look like the biggest fucking Dork you've
ever seen in your life.
Right?
This dude that you would,
you know.
And I said to my buddy,
that dude would whoop your fucking ass.
You realize that right?
Fuck,
what are you talking about?
That fucking drove whether he had a big
tradition sticker on the back of his
car,
like he goes to one of
the Jujitsu schools,
you know,
that's one of those dudes that like a
Joe Lowe's honor or one of those type of
guys you'd be like,
or who was the other kid that used
to fight for us and his whole yes,
him and no,
the other one,
there were two brothers.
His whole thing was kind
of like being a nerd.
Then you look like a nerd.
But he was a bad ass duty.
I think he came from Franklin's place.
The barn cat.
Yeah.
Fuck God dammit.
Hold on.
So those kids that look like,
you know,
if they said anything to you,
you'd be like,
dude,
I'll whoop your ass.
Those are the guys that will
put you in a fucking calm room.
It was,
look at the ears tend to McCrory.
Camden McCrory.
Mccrory was a bad mother fuckers.
Tough kid.
What is he doing these days?
Yeah,
I know where he's at.
He was tough.
So many guys in and out.
I mean we've seen so many finders.
How many fires did you guys just cut?
Um,
I think it was like 15 I think 50 shit.
A lot of people got bummed
out at some of them.
Right?
Like Fitch.
People got bummed out at.
Yeah.
If,
if there's,
if there's one you really want
to make a case for its Fitch,
you know what I mean?
But this is nothing new.
This didn't just start,
I mean we can just start say,
oh,
you know,
we're going to start cutting guys.
Guys get cut.
Every event,
every event we have,
there's a,
there's two things.
After every event,
there's a list of guys that their
contracts were almost up and need to be
reassigned and there's a list
of guys that are getting cut.
Is there a way to make more fights?
Is it that's a saturation point right now.
Know that that's what's funny
because everybody's like,
there's too many fights.
Too many fights.
If I can get to me it went too.
Fuck you talking about
there's too many fights.
Are there too many
football games out to me?
As long as we're putting on good fights,
people want to watch them.
That was one of the big problems with,
with our,
uh,
our other television deal.
They couldn't handle our content.
As we continue to grow,
we've got more and more
content that we need.
Meaning we need to put more fights on TV.
They couldn't handle the load spike
TV as opposed to fuel and Fox and Fox.
Right.
Fox can handle the amount of fights that
we want to do and I go to and they have
effects on or fuel on me all the
time and it's just fucking fights.
Fuel F it's like the UFC network dude.
Fuel has become awesome fucking channel.
If you sit down,
if you ever used to watch
fuel back in the old days,
you know it seemed like this,
you know your watch fuel
now it's fucking bad ass.
It's such a really good network.
If you love the UFC,
you got to watch fucking fuel.
I was there at this pool hall the other
day and they had the best of 2012 on and
it was like short attention span.
Theater was just bang,
Bang,
like highlight reels.
Not even the fights,
but the highlights of these fights.
So it was just insanity afterwards.
It was so hard to pay attention to pool
because it was just like head kick,
strangled,
fucking take down,
boom,
boom.
Just chaos.
It is.
It's awesome.
The other thing that they had on me and
the rents were in this meeting and the
rentals office,
and he's got this huge
fucking TV over on the side,
right?
And fuel was on and it
was like the prides,
like prides,
greatest knockouts ever.
And there were sitting there and we're
trying to talk and I keep looking over at
the fucking TV and I'm like,
Oh shit,
I forgot about that one.
And then we started watching the fucking
knock outs for a minute and then we'll
get back to the meeting.
I'm like,
dude,
turn this fucking TV off.
We can't,
we can't even fucking talk in here.
And uh,
and his fight scene.
But the thing is when
you see that old pride,
cause,
cause we used to watch pride ever when,
when,
uh,
back when the office was,
we own the whole building now,
but it used to be for Tita enterprises,
Gordon Biersch and then I had a fucking
broom closet over on the side over for
the UFC.
And we used to have,
this is his dad had this big library.
It was fucking awesome.
It was all pimped out.
They'd Gordon Biersch on tap and shit.
And it was really cool.
And we used to go there and we
used to watch all the pride fights.
And uh,
so when you see those old pride fights,
you know,
so it's just,
it's fun,
man.
I was the biggest fucking soccer.
Rob a fan man.
I was such a huge fan of soccer.
Sakuraba.
Yeah,
I was a huge,
huge pride fan.
You know,
they offered me the job as a commentator
and pride before I worked for you guys
and they offered me when
I was at your after party,
the pride Piaf came up to me.
I like to talk to you a medic [inaudible]
dude come and teddy footprint,
but I do come over here and I was like,
get the fuck outta here.
I'm not going to judge that.
We're definitely not doing that dude.
It was crazy.
It's,
it's,
I'm really surprised with
all the stories that I hear
and the stuff that I just know myself
about pride that more the more the
fighters will talk to me about what went
down in pride in the stuff to fucking
happen.
But I don't ever hear him
talk about it publicly.
Well,
we had an incident on the podcast and
he was telling us the whole Yakuza
connection.
It was fascinating.
Listen to him,
tell him about,
you know,
when it was like working back then,
working for these guys
and what do with it.
You know,
he became like friends with all these
Yakuza guys and got in with all the
accuser is like,
that's how they run things over there.
It's just,
that's the,
that's the price of doing business.
And pride was just completely
interconnected with it.
It's uh,
it's,
I mean it's a part of history,
you know,
but you know,
no more a part of history than the UFC,
but you really,
do you ever stop and think about how
crazy it is that you're a part of this
thing that,
like I said before,
just sort of exploded onto the,
the,
the popular culture that
didn't exist before.
When we were kids,
there was different martial arts.
It was judo and karate and all this shit
and no one knew what the fuck was the
best thing.
And everybody had their own beliefs.
But to have from 1993 to 2013 so this,
this,
this 20 year gap that we've seen,
we've seen the evolution of martial arts
just completely changed and this sport
just explode into the mainstream
and you're at the front of it.
Like that's a wild ride,
dude.
That's a wild ride for a regular guy.
When I met you,
I was on TV,
you are fucking regular guy.
He was a boxing manager and all of a
sudden you're like a celebrity now and
you're like a part of the host,
the ultimate fighter.
But somehow or another,
you've seamlessly,
sorta smoothly operated
through this strange thing.
But you're still the same guy.
I appreciate every other word.
It's fucking,
it's fucking guy with his fucking,
we fucking tell you about
fucking victor content.
You're the same guy.
I mean,
that's the same guy that I could have
talked to in 2001 we could have the same
conversation.
I mean,
obviously you're,
you've grown,
you've learned,
you've,
you've evolved and you know me,
I'm not saying you're like
you're stunted your growth.
What I'm saying you
that you have the same.
I don't,
it's not like,
I don't even know Dane anymore.
You and I have like,
we've never even had an argument ever,
and not even close.
I mean,
that's,
that's Kinda crazy too.
Yeah.
You're the same dude.
But you know,
the,
the reason that you and I have never had
an argument is because you're a fucking
good guy.
You're,
you're a solid guy.
You're a fucking standup guy.
Your word,
uh,
you know,
your word is your fucking word.
When you say you're going to do something,
you do it.
Um,
you know,
uh,
every however long it is,
we renegotiate your
fucking contract and we,
we re up you,
there's shit that I'll
fucking call you up and say,
dude,
I need a fucking favor.
And you do a favor.
And there's times when you say,
dude,
I need a favor and I'll
give you the favor.
But you,
you operate like a
fucking real guy and you,
and you're a real guy too.
Um,
and,
and that's really all
it takes to be whatever.
But the fact that you say
that I'm the same guy,
it means a lot to me.
And I appreciate that when,
when,
when people say that,
but um,
you know,
there's a lot of there,
there's a lot of myths out there about
me and there's a lot of things that are
really true.
The,
the,
the myths are that he's
this fucking tyrant that,
you know,
he wants to go out and destroy people's
lives and wants to do this and that and
all this other shit.
And then there's guys who fuck with us.
You know,
if you want to pick a fight with us,
they weren't going to fucking fight
difference.
And people understand,
have to understand that there's a big
difference between someone who's an
asshole and someone who just
doesn't like to be fucked with.
Yeah,
there's a big difference.
You're,
I mean,
and I'm just,
I'm not just saying this
because you're here.
You are remarkably nice person.
I've seen you deal with
fans and this is like,
oh,
you're cute.
Boris.
Is this on the Pug Dude?
If anybody says anything nice about me,
you're kissing my fucking ass.
It's like truth.
But that situation,
you,
you know,
you've handled it remarkably well.
You know,
we're remarkably well,
but when you get fucked with you
go crazy and you go over forward,
there's no doubt about it not,
and I'll admit to go to war,
there's no doubt.
And I will admit to that,
that it's,
it's probably like,
I don't know if it's my biggest
flaw or my biggest strength.
I taught
Dana White and the,
it was like,
I don't know what time it was.
It was late at night and I said,
uh,
I guess you,
I guess your fucking
celebrating right now.
It was right after Josh Barnett pissed
positive and they canceled the fade or
fight.
And you were like,
what?
I'm gambling right now.
What the fuck is going?
Never that like it was yesterday.
Fucking sit at the thing playing cards,
man.
And I don't ever answer my fucking phone.
I'm putting in,
I'm like,
oh fuck.
Rogan's calling me.
Why the fuck are broken?
Be calling me this,
this can't be good.
So you told me.
He's like,
he pissed.
I'm like,
what?
Like who went crazy?
I left my fucking chips on the table
and walk the fuck out of the place.
I remember you called.
It was shutting him down with buying
domination.
It was like her.
It was like Conan music was,
what did I say to you that
night when you called me?
I said,
you're fucking kidding me.
He did.
That's it.
They're done.
That debt.
The debt.
That was it.
Josh Barnett just killed him.
There was that.
It was a [inaudible] me.
There's been so many different times
over the past or you've gone to war with
whoever was running whatever organization
that was trying to fuck with you guys
and it's,
every guy has had the same ammo that that
we'd done it with it all come out and
talk shit about us.
They said,
yeah,
these guys don't fucking run it right.
We're actually going to be good to the
fighters and treat them good and we're
going to do,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The IFL,
they,
this wasn't that.
They're the rap.
That was the fucking funniest one ever.
Those guys were fucking
aware of Arizona Wolverines,
silverbacks bunch of different teams
and that was fucking hilarious.
Everybody has to try to figure
out their own slice of the,
that one was fine.
That one was actually fucking fun.
It's funny,
but here's what's,
what's unnecessary to compete.
You don't have to talk shit.
He don't,
you all you have to do,
I mean,
like I've even heard balance or talk shit.
Why would you do no,
no,
no.
Let,
let's be fair here.
Let's be fair.
You know,
Bella Tor has made a
couple of snide remarks,
fucking comments.
You know what I mean?
And it happens.
Uh,
it was the fucking PR guy
over at Spike David Schwartz.
He's the fucking guy.
He did some fucking punk ass shit
last season of the ultimate fighter.
And uh,
so what he was doing was every
time the ratings would come out,
he would send all the fucking,
oh,
the media fucking told me,
you think they're not going to
fucking tell me that you dick.
You know what I mean?
They'd tell me what this guy
was doing and I was like,
all right,
what was he doing?
He was sending them all the ratings.
Oh,
UFC,
it's tanking.
It's fucking tank.
And Oh,
so the,
okay.
The ultimate fighter doesn't work now
over there playing it to everybody.
This was when you guys had
already been on your way out.
So No.
All right.
So,
so everybody understands when,
when we found out that
we weren't doing a deal,
my beef is not with Bella Tor or
Bjork or any of those guys over there.
Not My beef.
His name is Bjorn,
Bjorn [inaudible].
He,
it's not my beef with them that,
that guys never really said anything.
He's had a couple of
little things that he said,
you know,
and,
and that's,
that's the whole a spike.
You know,
we want to,
there's a guy,
his name is Felipe Dumont.
Okay.
This guy runs Viacom.
Viacom.
The two guys who run Viacom couldn't
get along and got split down the middle.
Uh,
he runs Viacom,
which is spike MTV,
comedy central,
Nickelodeon and all that stuff.
Les Moonves runs CBS.
Okay.
So this guy,
Felipe doom on,
uh,
we start into our negotiations for our
new contract and this guy basically says
to us,
uh,
here's the deal,
sign it by tomorrow or fuck you
the fuck kind of shit is that?
This is,
yeah.
Through all those years
of being in business,
and I have a great working
relationship with spike,
with Kevin k with Doug Herzog,
the guy who runs comedy central and spike.
So this guy's like,
yeah,
fuck you.
We built you and what?
We'll just build another one,
you know,
and,
and the way that we are,
we're like fuck you the fuck
do you think you're talking?
He fucking,
you know what I mean?
You fucking built the UFC,
you piece of shit.
No,
you fucking didn't.
You know,
and so we knew we weren't
signing with these guys.
We knew we weren't signing.
So as soon as we're not signing,
they shut the faucet off.
All the things that we used to be able
to do on spike was done six months before
we were even gone.
Right.
So we go out and start shopping around.
We start talking to all the big guys.
We ended up doing this deal with,
with a Fox,
right?
We end up doing this great deal with Fox.
They're the greatest guys in the world.
Everything's great.
And now these guys start acting
like fucking a crazy ex girlfriend,
you know what I mean?
Like they wanted,
I said we went with somebody else.
No,
you,
what were they doing?
No,
you fucking
shit on us and disrespected us and
treated us like fucking assholes.
And then said you built the UFC.
Well this is all this one guy though.
Yeah.
That one guy.
Yeah,
Felipe Dumont.
So how's it going to get
to be ahead of Viacom?
How's that work?
I don't know how that works.
His real name is fillings
from fucking New Jersey.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
Full leap.
Duwan sounds like he's from
fucking France or something,
right?
He's here.
Yeah.
Wait,
in Israel.
His name is not Felipe.
Yeah,
it's Phil.
He's from New Jersey.
I'm decided to fucking,
I bust his balls.
I don't know.
I like that.
Put It on line because gentlemen,
so Jerry Rice,
what was his name?
The guy from Jerry Millen.
Yeah.
Wasn't that true with him?
Where the fuck is that guy?
Yeah,
exactly.
But didn't,
that guy wouldn't,
didn't like boss route and said
that that wasn't his real name.
Like it changes name.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I did.
I did hear that.
Oh,
me and him.
Yeah.
Well I know we've had some
the whole thing with your mom.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's sick.
Fuck that.
I wouldn't do that to my
worst enemy interviews.
Your mom.
Yeah,
no,
they did some low shit,
man.
That other,
other competitors have tried to do.
Shit.
It's parent.
My mom will go as low as she can go.
So you know,
anybody who wants to try to whatever,
it's just,
that's gotta be cute.
So,
so we ended up doing this deal of
Fox and these guys start acting like,
you know,
like we did something wrong to them.
And,
and,
and even the guys at spike,
like David Schwartz,
you know,
I worked with this guy
for six years and that,
and now you're really
going to do that to us.
You're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna send out these
things and put out these,
when people don't know the fall is
probably trying to protect his job.
And maybe guy like Felipe Dumont was
telling them to do something on an fit.
Felipe doesn't fucking
these things not look,
he says let's do this and they make
this decision to buy this thing and,
and,
and do whatever.
You know,
he's not involved in
the day to day at Spike.
They spent 50 million for Bella tour.
I don't know about that.
You don't know.
But a lot of people don't really,
well,
there was a lot of you,
do you think that,
I don't know how much money,
uh,
the,
the Bjorn guy put in himself,
but there were a lot of investors,
um,
and uh,
Viacom had to go buy
out all the investors.
Right?
What,
50 billion?
I don't know.
You know,
it depends on what number.
I,
I don't believe that number.
Do you think Viacom's running it now?
Oh yeah.
Hundred percent.
So what does Bjorn,
a figurehead,
those guys,
those guys are,
they,
they own the majority of the company.
Then they're making the
decisions over there.
I'm sure that guy is over there putting
together fights and doing whatever.
But let me tell you what there,
there's,
there's a guy over there.
What the Hell is his name?
Uh,
there's a guy over there.
Let me remember.
He was a fucking super sharp dude.
If I a calm guy over there via comments,
double,
triple sharp and he,
I can't remember his name.
I know.
I'll remember suspect for the guy.
Yeah,
no,
I know,
but I'm so busy.
Like I'm so bad with names like guys,
the guy w w with Viacom,
he's high up guys.
What's his name?
I was just talking
about him the other day,
but this guy is super smart and I
guarantee you if there's anybody that's
involved in trying to figure
out how to build this thing,
he's the guy in there doing it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a fascinating thing to stay.
Um,
I liked Jimmy Smith.
I think he does a great job,
you know,
over at belter and I think
they've got some good fights,
but it's,
uh,
it's so interesting seeing how the
UFC has become like Kleenex or,
you know,
uh,
it's become,
it's become like
cute tops.
I mean,
it's,
it's not even,
it's not even that.
Well,
no,
I agree.
But what people don't realize
is how hard we work at this.
It's like we get in that office in the
morning and we're there till fucking late
at night and everything we do,
we're,
we're absolute crazy about man.
And,
and,
and while building the business
and dealing with all the,
the,
the goofy shit that happens every day.
I'm putting out fires and things that
just happen dealing with the fucking
Culinary Union scumbags and,
uh,
all that stuff.
You know,
we still have to grow the business.
We still have to get
out there and do deals.
And it's crazy,
man.
It just never stops.
Thing is like a little baby
that you just can't leave alone.
You have to take care of it.
24,
seven.
Yeah.
It's a crazy fucker.
Never sleeps.
People don't know that.
The culinary business thing,
if folks don't know what
you're talking about,
the culinary union is been trying to
get the UFC shutdown because the UFC is
owned by [inaudible],
which is owned by the Fertittas
who also own station casinos,
which are non union.
The Culinary Union withstand a profit.
How much
the number is like 11 million a year,
11 million a year if they,
uh,
if they can get station casinos.
So they just constantly torment every day,
every day something goes out.
Right before I left here,
there was a flyer that came out where
they took a quote from Chael Sonnen and
uh,
you know,
it was channel on one of his
rants at a Q and a and uh,
they,
they put together a flyer and
they send it out to sponsors,
television networks,
everybody and they,
they do this every day and I'm
a fucking gold mine for them.
So I'm an every one of their flyers.
They created a website
about me and everything,
but it's amazing that anybody would even
listen to them at this point in time,
how much
they're losing.
They're losing tons of respect.
Yeah,
they're losing.
Yeah.
It's cool.
It's so true.
Parents.
Oh,
there's no doubt.
And,
and,
and as we continue to talk to,
uh,
a lot of the,
you know,
the sponsors and television networks
and everything that happens,
they actually can't stand the union now.
Well,
it's gangsterism oh dude,
these guys actually have gangster routes.
This is these guys literally,
I'm going to pull up the lineage of,
of the Las Vegas Culinary Union.
I want to get it to you.
It'd be great for you to read
gangsters killing people.
And Yeah,
literally gangsters is 11 million a year
and then go in union and the workers at
the casinos don't want this apparently.
Is that the case?
Or is exactly,
is that what they said?
Exactly.
Even if there's a story
even about the MGM,
how they ended up coming to
some deal with the union.
So what they do is they let the union
come into the hotel to get people to sign
up.
It took four years,
you know,
they're in the fucking kitchen,
down with people eat everyday,
terrorizing the people to sign.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's a fucking nightmare,
man.
Bad people.
They're bad people.
Well,
Vegas has a map,
then they start,
then they start like for instance,
man fucking Mandy Moore,
right?
Mandy Moore is one of the
sweetest people you'll ever meet.
Yeah.
One of the nicest fucking people.
And one of the most
unlikely UFC fans on earth.
Right?
Fucking sweetheart.
The girl is,
if you ever talked to her,
there's not a bad bone
in her fucking body.
These fucking piece of shit.
Scum bags start hammering Disney going.
Cause you know she did that movie tangled.
How could you be in business with somebody
like Mandy Moore who supports the UFC
and did you know that they're against
gay people and did you know that they,
that they fucking hate black people.
And did you know that they
hate fucking yellow people?
And did you know that,
that this,
that and did you know that the
guy who runs it swears and he,
and he's like a ball Nazi and like
all this fucking shit they send it to,
to,
to Disney about Mandy Moore.
What kind of a fucking piece of shit do
you need to be to fucking do that demand
anymore?
This is a strange,
strange place.
And the fact that that can still
exist in a place like Vegas.
Vegas has so much old school about it
when it comes to to that kind of stuff.
That's true.
And which people are so scummy.
Do you like living there,
don't you?
I do
think about doing a weekly show.
I think about like if I had
like a weekly show at a casino,
like I could do like a smaller casino or
like a hard rock type of thing and have
some kind of a weekly show.
What would that be like?
I think you'd be able
to live in I think then.
Yeah,
but I don't think I could live there.
Oh,
you mean live there?
No,
can never live Joe.
Let me tell you what,
if you lived in Vegas,
you could set up a shop just like this.
Uh,
you know,
even bigger and better.
I'd be cheaper.
There's no taxes.
You know,
you pay no state tax down,
but you've got to live in Vegas,
but when you live there,
you can stay away from the Strip and
all that shit and not even know you're
there.
It's like being near Chernobyl.
You're going to get the residual,
get the black rain of Vegas lives.
They're live.
They're not even ship.
I'm telling you how far out do you live?
How far away you are,
the way you're fucking built.
There's no way.
I'm probably,
I live in what's called Summerlin,
which is probably 15
minutes away from the strip.
I would live in the mountains.
I'd have to get on a
snowmobile to drive you down.
The way you can take a car.
You could live on a,
you know,
Mt.
Charleston,
there's just some cool places up there.
How far away is that from Vegas?
20 minutes.
I still couldn't live there.
I have kids.
How do you have your kids in Vegas?
You don't have any problem
with your kids being near that,
that fucking giant battery of sin.
I grew up with big,
pulsating battery of,
I grew up there.
Look how great I turned out.
I guess if you grew up there,
you wouldn't be worried about it.
I'm an alien and looking
at it from the outside,
I come and tell you what hung over going,
get me the fuck outta here.
And I couldn't imagine living there.
I got a place in Laguna,
right?
I've got a house in Vegas
and I got a hundred acres
in Maine.
Okay.
You could fucking live.
You see the shit that I've seen
happen up in Maine to kids,
kids getting fucked up on drugs,
pregnant at fucking 16.
Um,
you name it.
It doesn't matter where you live,
as long as you stay on top of your kids,
you've just got to,
you know,
stay on him.
That's true.
Yeah.
I mean,
I would,
I would imagine at least maybe if they're
aware that something like Vegas exists
early on,
maybe there'd be a knock
elated to the pressures,
you know,
maybe,
I don't know.
Fuck.
By talking about,
I wouldn't want to own live in Vegas.
Yeah.
But I'd like to do a weekly show there.
It seems like should be a fun thing to do.
You should do a residency
somewhere with theater.
Shut up.
What do you have to do to do that?
That's a good room.
Do you have to hug him?
No.
Yeah,
you did the Louie Anderson
Theater does a good room.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Small,
but it's nice.
It's a palace.
Vegas does not have a lot of
good places to do comedy anymore.
Yeah.
They used to have what they did.
They do a lot of shit at the Mirage.
Did I?
Yeah,
that's right.
it has ray Romano.
They have Kevin and James.
Yeah,
they have,
um,
Tosh,
uh,
is there,
um,
there's a bunch of comedians there.
They've got a pretty good comedy scene
or the laugh factory.
Penn teller likes it.
Like pen.
I know Penn for it pretty well.
He fucking loves,
I see him every morning.
His kids get let go to the
same school mind is really.
Yeah.
And what kind of school is that?
Like a private school?
Yeah.
What do the kids like?
Normal kids.
Yeah.
It's the greatest private school there.
There's a fucking freaky
private school there too.
And my kids started there.
I got him the fuck out of that place.
Yeah,
it was like fucking Germany,
19 fucking 42 what do
you mean it's just bad?
Kids aren't allowed to talk at lunch
everywhere they walk in the school,
they have to walk in a single file line.
How the fuck do you not talk at lunch?
Single file line in Vegas.
Yeah.
You want to hear it?
You want to hear the best making hookers?
He's going to snap back the other way.
This school's expensive as hell.
Right?
So one day I fucking
show up at the school.
They call us in and they're like,
yeah,
your son's having trouble reading.
Okay,
so what?
Yeah,
he's having trouble reading.
It's,
it's a,
it's a problem.
What the fuck am I paying you for?
Aren't you supposed to be
show saw this conversation.
They were out of that school that day.
So what was I saying?
What you need to teach him.
That was like,
like fucking one of these elitist
schools where you're either super fucking
smart and you pick up their curriculum
because they don't really teach what they
have a curriculum there that the kids
have to follow these kids and fucking
kindergarten get buried in homework.
It's one of these places
where you go there.
Every fucking mother,
their faces are fucking sewn
back to their ears and you know,
they put on fucking diamonds
the size of this egg to go,
you know,
they're all done up at fucking six in
the morning to take their kids to school
and I lasted,
I lasted a month at that freak show.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I paying you for?
I might,
aren't I paying you to
teach them how to read?
You get very angry when
we renew reenacting this.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
that's a touchy subject.
I
see it.
It brings you,
right.
I have,
how do we get anywhere
on that tree school?
Elementary School.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
You training people for the Rhino,
but that's where you'd
put your kids at Dawson.
It's a school over there.
School.
Cool.
Yeah.
I love it.
I'm not going to Vegas and I'm moving.
I just say,
I said,
you're moving.
I'm trying to get back to the mountains.
I'm trying to go.
You go back to Colorado.
It's fucking crazy.
You find out what that's all about.
You got fucking loved it.
Saber Tooth Tigers in your
backyard and she'll me.
I'm fine.
It wasn't for Mrs Rogan.
I'd be back there right now.
Colorado is actually a cool place.
I like it too.
Well for me too.
It's also the dealing with
the giant crowds of people
at fcs and a comedy shows.
I like the contrast to being in the woods.
I liked,
I liked the contrast of the bolt.
I like it.
I think it's good for you,
man.
That's a great,
the only problem with Colorado is
you've got to have that winner.
Got To go through those winners,
man.
It ain't that bad.
Colorado when I was not that bad.
Crazy.
It's not that bad,
dude.
I'm telling you,
I'm too old for that shit
in Vegas and it's 40 out.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this shit?
I 40 well,
Vegas is 40 and cold
because there's no heart.
There's no hard to study.
Different kind of cold.
That's a fucking demonic.
Coal as funny.
It creeps into your marrow.
I like Vegas.
I'm just kidding.
I would like coming in
and getting out though.
But you know,
the problem is I'm always in town.
If I'm in there with Eddie Bravo,
we're always hammered,
you know?
Uh,
if I'm there for the fights,
it's the place,
dude.
You know?
You know what I feel that way.
That's how La is for me.
Oh yeah.
We're not coming to la.
I'm like,
this place is the fucking devil.
And I live in Vegas for Christ's sake.
And I'm like,
get me the fuck is way with me kids.
He'd go out and drink.
So you're avoiding alcohol completely now.
Wow.
So why don't you try a little
weed just a little bit.
I haven't drank in six weeks.
You can get medical marijuana,
medical from a doctor.
Never been into it.
Leighton's you right the fuck out.
Like yeah,
equilibrium,
all that shit.
Your Vertigo,
so,
so if it did that,
you'd have to be high.
Yes.
Yeah I can.
I can't do it.
No Fun.
Trust me.
He would love it.
It'd be fine.
Let's try it right now.
Too Old.
I'm too old.
There's no such thing.
Just,
you know,
just fucking take a week off
when you have a week off,
give it a shot.
Do you let me know.
Let me know when you're ready.
Just,
you know when you got to fucking
earache one day you're like,
listen,
I can't take this.
Take me somewhere.
I come at
like,
if you're going to do it,
just don't deal with anybody else.
Don't deal with the,
to this motherfucker will bring a gravity
bong puts you on on the first day.
He got to go slowly.
That's what I gotta do is get
the tooth high and then I can,
I'm telling you right now,
I'm late to every fucking
thing I do with this guy.
It's unbelievable.
It's like great guy.
He's like my other little kid.
But he said,
your personality,
it's fun to have you and it,
it's fun
to have her tell you what,
there's never a fucking day that you wake
up that the tooth in a bad mood tooth
ever has a bad day.
Never like fucking what's
the amount of tooth?
Well,
why are you upset to that today?
Just a fucking,
he's never ever man
listening to this and the podcasts going,
what is this guy talking about?
Who the fuck is the team?
Right?
This guy named Nick.
Good Dude.
We talk like we're talking about fucking,
you know,
Brad Pitt or something.
Exactly.
Everybody should know that too.
Well,
we got to wrap this thing up
because at three hours in,
we turn into a Pumpkin,
but uh,
we finally did it.
We finally had a pause for three hours.
Yeah.
Wow.
How long was I here?
Two plus two.
That's my skill.
Dana White's my skill is I can get people
to talk for long periods of time to be
comfortable.
You are a talented motherfucker.
Joe Rogan.
I admit I'm not talented,
but I'm good at the things that I'm
good at talking and talking shit.
I'm a professional shit
talker because all this,
all this shit talking to
in between this and comedy.
That's what makes doing
commentary so easy.
So before we wrap,
did you hit all the things
that the fans wanted to hear?
What else?
What else did I want to know?
The fuck what they want
these crazy assholes.
They want to know during the
war you show cruel to the foods.
Why are you loyal to the things
cruel to the fans and live them.
Actually said that.
That was one of the
things that a guy tweeted.
He,
this is this,
what did I lie about?
Eye exam that breaches the liar.
I'm probably the most fucking
honest guy that could,
uh,
you know,
here's a queen.
I can't tell you guys
everything all the fucking time.
I know you love to like talk
shit to people on Twitter.
So find this guy's name is
Sonny said Jeezy you could fly.
I retweeted it.
It says as Dana,
how often he lives on purpose
to the media and the fans.
And that was his tweet.
I don't know all the things
you could possibly ask him.
So of course me being an idiot,
that's the one guy respond
all these other people,
they was,
they asked me some legitimate questions
about the future of MMA and I ignore it.
I say to this guy,
sounds like someone need to hug.
You know,
it's funny too,
the one thing about Twitter
that you'll always notice,
you get the guy that starts
talking fucking Shit,
right?
He's saying all this crazy shit.
You're like,
you know,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna.
I want to find out more about this guy.
Let me click on his fucking,
you know,
it's the guy who's got his
fucking shirt off flexing,
right?
He's got to fucking followers.
And uh,
you know,
he's telling you what a
fucking Douche bag you are.
Yeah.
Right?
So then you get this guy,
this guy today,
fucking glasses,
the whole thing.
It looks like,
you know,
and he and his buddies
talking shit to me in his bio.
It says,
uh,
yeah,
I'm the guy that girls like to bring
home to their parents and you know,
I'm faithful and I'm
cute and I'm Christian.
Are you fucking seriously
talking shit to me with,
that's when you wrote
down on your fucking bio,
dude,
I am going to smash you.
Yeah,
oof.
Nasty as gay shit written
to me by Christians.
But I suppose it could,
you know,
Christians like you
look down at the thing,
you know God love and Christian God.
God bless America.
God bless the USA and made
of you fucking Queer Homo.
Why you to go sub?
Karlyn was called it's deck,
some Dick Ball rider.
Thank you for Jesus.
Fuck,
make up your mind.
You're fucking,
he's like,
oh,
that's it.
A couple of years ago I asked you,
Joe,
I just saw a cyborg fight or
something like that and I was like,
what?
UFC ever get females in it?
And you were like,
Dana was never elected happen.
What made it change?
Because I,
I'm,
I think it's the greatest idea ever.
Ronda Rousey,
when I met her,
I saw some more fights,
then I met her.
Um,
and then we sat down and
talked one day and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
she's a marketing goldmine
and she's fucking legit.
She's super legit.
She's hot as fuck.
And she's angry.
She's angry,
man.
She is angry.
She really is angry people.
So great.
When you meet her and you really
fucking hang out with her,
this girl is a fucking,
she she's and look at that car.
She's a finisher.
Look at that card.
Leo Machida versus Dan Henderson.
Great fucking fight.
Dan Henderson,
the only guy to ever hold two
weight classes consecutively,
the 183 and the 205 pound title,
the same fucking time and
pride taken on Leo Machida,
former light heavyweight champion,
one of the top two or three light
heavyweights on the planet earth without a
doubt.
And then you got Josh
neer versus court McGee.
So Courtney is going on in one 70.
Is that what that is?
Those are those there.
Uh,
I think that one is,
uh,
is that one on the main card?
That was the main card core.
Maggie's a great fucking fight.
Well,
that one's not the effects one is
the main event for the prelims.
The courts running shop.
Oh,
Lavar Johnson.
Yeah.
Fx.
So court McGee has dropped down to one 70.
Is that what that is?
It must be.
I mean,
Josh neer isn't going up to one 85.
Right.
All right.
Is that right?
Am I right?
I pics in here.
It's a big fucking kid to get huge.
His endurance is staggering.
That guy has got incredible endurance.
You know,
you've runs like,
like five minute miles with
a fucking weight vest on.
That kid's an animal.
That's a fun fight.
It's a great fight.
And then so is Josh Koscheck Robbie Lawler
excited for that fight?
That fight is going to be fucking crazy.
What else is on this card?
Oh,
we gotta go.
We gotta wrap.
[inaudible] favorite that's
flying under the radar.
Yeah.
That's a great fucking fight.
Men Javan fader or filtrate or
tomorrow and tomorrow be mile.
I haven't men Jabar fought GSP the
first fight of his fucking career.
He weighs 135 pounds.
Okay.
I mean,
he would fight favor.
All right.
He wouldn't fight fate or if
you thought you looked up,
I haven't mentioned barn fader.
He would fight him.
That's a,
there's a,
this is a great card man.
I'm fucking pumped.
And that's this weekend,
7:00 PM Eastern,
10:00 PM
sorry.
In Anaheim.
If you're in la,
are there any tickets available?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they're still ticking.
The great part is it's
all the cheap seats,
man.
There's like a,
there's a few hundred cheap tickets.
It's the cheapest tier.
Usually when,
when you,
when you don't sell,
it's usually that middle
tier that doesn't sell.
These are the cheapest tickets.
This thing is going to be a sellout.
Well,
it's a great card too.
On top of that,
there's a,
the FX fights as a Brendan
Shab versus Lavar Johnson.
That's a crazy fucking heavyweight fight.
That's going to be a great fight.
I can't wait to see that.
Holy Shit.
And uh,
that's the,
so the prelims,
they started on Facebook,
then they're on Fx.
And then of course the
main card is on paper view.
Robbie Lawler versus Josh Koscheck,
a crazy fucking fight.
Court McGee versus Josh neer.
That's a great,
Josh neer is one of my favorite guys.
I like watching that kid fight.
Never in a is awesome.
He's gritty is fun.
The kids,
he's a savage man.
Jabbar and favor is going to be fantastic.
Then of course Henderson and
Machida is a fucking amazing fight.
I can't wait to see that fight and
I can't wait to see Ronnie route.
Ronda Rousey and Carmouche.
Liz Carmouche is a Badass bitch too.
She's really tough kids.
They're both tough.
That's going to be fantastic.
[inaudible] man.
She throws crazy on Orthodox.
Shit's been an elbows,
uh,
flying knees and her ground and pound
is nasty and she knows is a huge
opportunity.
She's going to go for broke.
It's going to be chaos.
Dana White.
I'm glad we're friends.
Me Too,
brother.
I love you.
I love you too.
All right folks,
that's it.
Show's over.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Thanks to ana.com for
supporting the podcast.
Go to O.
N.
I t.
Use the code name.
Rogan,
save yourself 10% off any and
all supplements this weekend.
This Friday night.
I'm at the Goo.
Where am I at?
What is it called?
Them?
The Grove.
The Grove in Anaheim with Joey Diaz.
That's tomorrow night.
Uh,
there's a few tickets available.
There's less than a hundred as of today.
And uh,
Brian,
where's that big show in?
Um,
San Diego.
March 14th,
go to American Comedy Co.
Dot Com.
It's in San Diego.
It's gonna be a test swatch show.
All right,
my friends.
Uh,
so that's it for this week.
Next week we got a,
we got some great shit
coming up next week.
We got Dan Carlin is coming on next week.
Oh,
is that next week in a minute.
Hold on.
Where are we?
What is it?
Oh yeah,
Dan Carlin.
Um,
yeah,
he's on Monday and then
we got Dunkin on Tuesday.
Eddie,
Eddie Hong on a Wednesday cause any
harm is a guy from vice magazine.
Oh,
sweet.
Cool fucking dude.
I'm real excited to have him on.
And then next weekend we're in Columbus,
Cincinnati on Friday night,
Columbus on Saturday night,
uh,
tickets still available for both shows.
All right.
You freaks.
We love the Shit Outta Ya
and we'll see you soon.
Thank you.
Yeah.